What's better than a well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribby you ordered without even leaving the kitty pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Hello, and welcome to your second drink of Ben Franklin, one of my personal favorite episodes.
有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、纹理完美的肋眼牛排更好的呢？是由Instacart购物者精心挑选并送到您家门口的、在烧烤架上滋滋作响、纹理完美的肋眼牛排。是您甚至不用离开儿童戏水池就能订购的、纹理完美的肋眼牛排。无论您的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart都能满足您的需求。下载Instacart应用程序，享受前三笔订单$0配送费。服务费、除外条款和条款适用。Instacart，超额交付的杂货。您好，欢迎收看本期《本·富兰克林》，这是我个人最喜欢的剧集之一。
This is a great breakdown, Andy Daly, who played Ben Franklin's in an audio clips. I went back to our mailbag after this episode aired, and you all noticed a few things we missed, so let's get to it. Gabby A said, around the five-minute mark, Todd Packer and Michael do this bit where they see each other and Todd pretends to kick Michael. Ryan is seen smiling, sort of finding the moment amusing. But was that BJ breaking? Okay, Gabby, I went and looked. Mm-hmm. It is 100% BJ breaking. I totally saw it. Gabby had said in her letter, like, I don't think that Ryan, the character, would be this amused by this tomfoolery. And yeah, no. But BJ, yes. It's BJ. Well, during this episode, I became somewhat obsessed with sweater dimples.
这是一个很棒的解析，安迪·戴利在音频片段中扮演了本·富兰克林。这集播出后，我回看了我们的邮件袋，你们都注意到了一些我们遗漏的事情，所以让我们开始吧。加比·A说，在大约五分钟的时候，托德·帕克和迈克尔演了一段戏，他们看到对方，托德假装踢迈克尔。瑞安在笑，觉得这一刻很有趣。但那是BJ笑场了吗？好吧，加比，我去看了。嗯，百分之百是BJ笑场了。我完全看到了。加比在信中说，我不认为瑞安这个角色会觉得这种胡闹很有趣。是的，没错。但BJ，是的。是BJ。嗯，在这一集里，我有点沉迷于毛衣上的褶皱。
Oh, I remember you did a whole deep dive. Those are the bumps that you guys. get when you hang a sweater on a hanger. And I had not heard the term sweater dimple before. I'd not, I've never heard of this thing. I mean, I experienced it. Right, but you didn't know there was a term. Correct. Well, we got some mail, and I want to read this from Cassandra V because I guess I missed one. She wrote in and said, Angela, Kelly's sweater also has nipples. Check the conference room scene right after the awkward president exchange. It's around 10 minutes and 40 seconds on the Netflix version. She has sweater nipples near the bra line on her back. How was that sweater hung? L.O.L. It looks almost like it was folded and hung with a pants hanger. Yes, I saw it. It's so
哦，我记得你做了一次深入的研究。那些就是你们把毛衣挂在衣架上时产生的凸起。我以前没听说过“毛衣褶皱”这个词。我从来没听说过这个东西。我的意思是，我经历过。没错，但你不知道有个术语。正确。好吧，我们收到了一些邮件，我想读一下卡桑德拉·V的来信，因为我想我漏掉了一个。她写道，安吉拉，凯利的毛衣也有乳头。看看尴尬的总统交流之后的会议室场景。在Netflix版本上大约是10分40秒。她的背部在胸罩线附近有毛衣乳头。那件毛衣是怎么挂的？哈哈。看起来几乎像是折叠起来用裤架挂的。是的，我看到了。这太
weird. Yeah, they're really pointy towards the back. Yes, yes. Like super pointing out, like kind of above her shoulder blades kind of. It's true, true sweater dimple action. And Deborah E wrote in to say, sorry, this is not a question, but a, did you know? A quick emergency fix to the, quote, shoulder bumps is just a mist of water to dampen the area and then a few taps of the finger and the bumps will disappear. You can also dry the area with a blow dryer. Oh. I have done the blow dryer bit. You have? I have wet the area and done the blow dryer. How often in general do you get your iron out? Oh, man, I used to get it out all the time. And it's funny you asked this because this morning I almost ironed the pants I have one, but I couldn't find my. Oh, so I guess not very often if you can't even
奇怪了。是的，它们真的向后尖尖的。是的，是的。就像超级尖出来，有点像在她的肩胛骨上方。这是真的，真正的毛衣褶皱动作。黛博拉·E写信说，抱歉，这不是一个问题，而是一个“你知道吗？”。对于所谓的“肩部凸起”，一个快速的紧急修复方法只是喷一点水来湿润该区域，然后用手指轻拍几下，凸起就会消失。你也可以用吹风机吹干该区域。哦。我做过吹风机那部分。你做过？我弄湿了该区域并用了吹风机。你通常多久拿出一次熨斗？哦，天哪，我过去经常把它拿出来。你问这个很有趣，因为今天早上我差点熨了我穿的裤子，但我找不到我的。哦，所以我想如果你连
find it. It must have been a while. But you know, Josh organizes stuff and he puts everything up high. Yeah. So I think he's moved it from where I had it and now it's up high somewhere. Well, I know your laundry room and your cabinets are very high. They're high for me. I know because I live with a tall person who helped design that room. I'm talking about you, Josh. Well, one of my fast packs for this episode was about Ben Franklin. And we got a letter from Kat Q, who said, quote, just wanted to add that I was hoping you would cover one more interesting fact about Ben Franklin. I am from Franklin, Massachusetts, which is named after Ben Franklin because he donated a set of books to the town in 1790, which then started the nation's first and still running public library. Thanks, Ben.
都找不到，那就不经常用了。一定有一段时间了。但你知道，乔什整理东西，他把所有东西都放得很高。是的。所以我认为他把它从我放的地方移走了，现在它在某个高处。嗯，我知道你的洗衣房和橱柜非常高。对我来说很高。我知道，因为我和一个帮设计那个房间的高个子住在一起。我说的是你，乔什。嗯，我这一集的快速事实之一是关于本·富兰克林的。我们收到了凯特·Q的来信，她说：“只想补充一点，我希望你能再讲一个关于本·富兰克林的有趣事实。我来自马萨诸塞州的富兰克林，它是以本·富兰克林命名的，因为他在1790年向该镇捐赠了一套书籍，这开启了全国第一个至今仍在运营的公共图书馆。谢谢你，本。”
Oh, didn't know that. Didn't know that. Okay, well, you know the funny runner at the end of the episode where Dwight is interrogating Ben Franklin? Yes. They're in the break room. And Jim has Dwight convinced that he is the real Ben Franklin. Yes, and Dwight is trying to like stump him with a bunch of questions.
哦，不知道那个。不知道那个。好吧，你知道剧集结尾处德怀特审问本·富兰克林的那个有趣的跑题吗？是的。他们在休息室。吉姆让德怀特相信他就是真正的本·富兰克林。是的，德怀特正试图用一堆问题难倒他。
That's right. Well, Katrina N. wrote in to ask, why is Dwight holding a football in the break room? Well, Katrina, I went and looked in our shooting draft and here is why. It reads like this. Interior break room, Dwight interrogates Ben Franklin. Dwight. So, Ben, it's pretty cool you invented electricity. After work, you must have gone out for a cold beer. Ben Franklin. Cold? We always enjoy our ale at room temperature. Dwight, of course, of course. Dwight pulls out an American football. Dwight says, hey, after work, we should go play football, Ben Franklin. Ben Franklin. Indeed, but pray tell, what is that?
没错。好吧，卡特里娜·N写信问，为什么德怀特在休息室拿着一个橄榄球？好吧，卡特里娜，我去看了我们的拍摄草稿，原因如下。它是这样写的：室内休息室，德怀特审问本·富兰克林。德怀特：所以，本，你发明了电，这太酷了。下班后，你一定出去喝过冷啤酒吧。本·富兰克林：冷的？我们总是喜欢室温的麦芽酒。德怀特：当然，当然。德怀特拿出一个美式橄榄球。德怀特说：嘿，下班后，我们应该去踢橄榄球，本·富兰克林。本·富兰克林：确实，但请告诉我，那是什么？
Football is played with a round ball that you kick. Dwight, right, right. Whatever was I thinking. Here, have some chocolate. Then Franklin, chocolate, how did you acquire it? It is a delicacy in the Amazon, but it has not yet been imported to the United States. Oh my gosh, so that's where it starts in the episode. Those first two were cut out. Yeah. And lady, I even went to the Peacock Superfan episode to see if I could solve this football question,
橄榄球是用一个圆球踢的。德怀特：对，对。我到底在想什么。来，吃点巧克力。本·富兰克林：巧克力，你是怎么得到的？它是亚马逊的一种美味，但还没有进口到美国。哦，天哪，所以这就是它在剧集里的开始。前两个被剪掉了。是的。而且女士，我甚至去了Peacock的超级粉丝剧集，看看我是否能解决这个橄榄球问题，
and that stuff is not in there. That's why he's still holding it. Yes. There you go. Good sleuthing. Thank you. You know, I love a little bit of a mom detective in our, archives of scripts and candy bags. I know you do. I got this question and I couldn't find the answer and
那些东西不在里面。这就是为什么他还在拿着它。是的。给你。侦探工作做得好。谢谢。你知道，我喜欢在我们的脚本和糖果袋档案中有一点妈妈侦探的感觉。我知道你喜欢。我收到了这个问题，我找不到答案，
I said, Angela, can you dive into the scripts? I know it's your favorite thing. And I was so excited. All right. Well, listen, one last thing before we go. My play, Ashland Avenue, starts previews in two weeks. And then the play officially opens September 15, but we need audiences for previews too. This is like an important part of the play process where you get audience feedback and then we might make little tweaks. So it's like you're part of the process. It's one of my favorite parts of being in a play. So listen, you can get tickets at goodmantheater.org. Please come see the show. I can't wait to see it. You're coming to the opening lately. I sure am. You betcha. All right, folks, well, that's all we got. So please enjoy our second drink of Ben Franklin. I'm Jenna Fisher.
我说，安吉拉，你能深入研究一下脚本吗？我知道这是你最喜欢的事情。我太兴奋了。好吧，听着，在我们走之前还有最后一件事。我的戏剧《阿什兰大道》两周后开始预演。然后这出戏在9月15日正式开演，但我们需要观众来预演。这就像是戏剧过程中重要的一部分，你可以获得观众反馈，然后我们可能会做一些小的调整。所以就像你是过程的一部分。这是我参与戏剧最喜欢的部分之一。所以听着，你可以在goodmantheater.org买票。请来看演出。我迫不及待想看了。你最近要来参加开幕式吗？我当然会。你打赌。好吧，伙计们，这就是我们所有的内容。所以请享受我们的第二杯《本·富兰克林》。我是珍娜·费舍尔。
And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Angela, I am so excited. I'm so excited. This is one of my favorite episodes. I watched it again this morning. I know you did do. And just for joy. Just to start my day off with a laugh. I have been giddy. Guys, it is Season 3, episode 14, Ben Franklin. Oh, God. It's so good. It's just when I say it. It was written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Randall Einhorn. Here's a summary. Michael wants to celebrate
我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。安吉拉，我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。我今天早上又看了一遍。我知道你看了。只是为了快乐。只是为了用笑声开始我的一天。我一直很兴奋。伙计们，这是第三季第14集，《本·富兰克林》。哦，天哪。太棒了。就是当我这么说的时候。它是由敏迪·卡灵编写，兰德尔·艾因霍恩导演的。这是一个摘要。迈克尔想要庆祝
Phyllis's upcoming wedding by organizing two parties, one for the ladies and one for the guys. He asks Jim to hire a stripper for the ladies, and Dwight is going to hire one for the guys. So Dwight hires Elizabeth, who is going to end up giving Michael advice on his love life. Jim hires historical speaker, Ben Franklin. Also in this episode, Karen confronts Pam about her past with Jim. Oh, if you want a few minutes of awkward, awkward in the kids. kitchen. Awkward in the kitchen. It's a new song. Yeah. All right, guys. Fast fact number one. Ben Franklin. You might know him as the guy on the $100 bill or the inventor of the lightning rod or the bifocal lenses. Or maybe you know that he is the only founding father to sign all four documents credited with creating the United States of America. That includes the Declaration of Independence, the Treaty of Paris, And the Constitution.
菲利斯即将到来的婚礼，组织两场派对，一场给女士，一场给男士。他让吉姆为女士们雇一个脱衣舞娘，德怀特要为男士们雇一个。所以德怀特雇了伊丽莎白，她最终会给迈克尔关于他的爱情生活的建议。吉姆雇了历史演讲者，本·富兰克林。在这一集中，凯伦还就她与吉姆的过去与帕姆对质。哦，如果你想要几分钟的尴尬，厨房里的尴尬。厨房里的尴尬。这是一首新歌。是的。好吧，伙计们。快速事实一。本·富兰克林。你可能知道他是100美元钞票上的人，或者是避雷针或双焦镜片的发明者。或者也许你知道他是唯一签署了被认为创建了美利坚合众国的所有四份文件的开国元勋。这包括《独立宣言》、《巴黎条约》和《宪法》。
But here are some other interesting facts about Benjamin Franklin. What? He had 16 siblings. His poor mother. His mother was pregnant her whole life. Her whole life, she was pregnant. My grandfather was one of 11. He was like the third to last born, and his mom named him Plenty.
但这里还有一些关于本杰明·富兰克林的有趣事实。什么？他有16个兄弟姐妹。他可怜的母亲。他母亲一生都在怀孕。她一生都在怀孕。我祖父是11个孩子之一。他是倒数第三个出生的，他妈妈给他取名叫“足够”（Plenty）。
Oh, no. And in my family, we've always been like, what does that mean? She was just like, I need a break. Hey, that's plenty. Take a pause. They could have named him enough or finished. Stay off me. Yeah, get away.
哦，不。在我们家里，我们总是说，那是什么意思？她只是觉得，我需要休息。嘿，这足够了。停一下。他们本可以叫他“够了”或“结束”。离我远点。是的，走开。
This is my kid, get away. Well, Ben Franklin's father had two wives. Oh, good. He had seven children with his first wife, and then he had ten children with his second wife. Ben Franklin was the 15th child in that birth order. That's still, that's a lot of snacks. Oh, my God. It's a lot of...
这是我的孩子，走开。嗯，本·富兰克林的父亲有两个妻子。哦，很好。他和第一任妻子有七个孩子，然后他和第二任妻子有十个孩子。本·富兰克林是出生顺序中的第15个孩子。那仍然，那有很多零食。哦，我的天哪。那有很多……
I mean, you're making a lot of... Can I have some waters? Yeah. Ben Franklin only had two years of a formal education. Wow. He was a vegetarian. Oh. Like your character of Angela Martin,
我的意思是，你正在制造很多……我能喝点水吗？是的。本·富兰克林只有两年的正规教育。哇。他是素食主义者。哦。就像你扮演的安吉拉·马丁这个角色，
this might explain why you were so taken with him in this episode. Oh, well, maybe. Mm-hmm. He started the first volunteer fire station in Philadelphia, and he invented an instrument called the Glass Armonica. That's not real. It's real. It was used by both Mozart and Beethoven. Here's what it is. It is basically, it is a series of glass orbs that you play by spinning them and then getting your finger wet and putting your finger on the orb. Oh, we've seen this. This is like in talent shows. Like seriously, a junior high talent show. There's like someone that sets up a table of glasses and then is like me for me, me, me, me, me, me.
这可能解释了为什么你在这一集中对他如此着迷。哦，好吧，也许吧。嗯。他在费城创办了第一个志愿消防站，他还发明了一种叫做玻璃琴的乐器。那不是真的。是真的。它被莫扎特和贝多芬使用过。这是它是什么。它基本上是一系列玻璃球，你通过旋转它们，然后弄湿手指并把手指放在球上来演奏。哦，我们见过这个。这就像在才艺表演中。就像严肃地说，初中才艺表演。有个人摆了一桌子玻璃杯，然后就像“咪，咪，咪，咪，咪，咪”。
Yeah, Ben Franklin invented that. Okay, and here's the thing. He would later write about this invention. I loved this, quote, of all of my inventions, the glass harmonica has given me the greatest personal satisfaction. More than the bifocals. Why do I feel like if you went over to his house, he was always busting out his glass harmonica. And you're just like, hey, I just want it. And he's like, me, me, we're like, okay, Ben, we get it.
是的，本·富兰克林发明了那个。好吧，事情是这样的。他后来写到了这个发明。我喜欢这个，引用：“在我所有的发明中，玻璃琴给了我最大的个人满足感。”比双焦镜片还多。为什么我觉得如果你去他家，他总是拿出他的玻璃琴。而你只是说，嘿，我只是想要它。而他说，咪，咪，我们就像，好吧，本，我们明白了。
We get it. Exactly. So Ben Franklin was a prolific inventor, you know, the kite in the air and all the yada yada. Yeah. Then he died of a disease that could have been treated by antibiotics today. What did he die from? Well, some people think he died from complications of syphilis, but he died from a disease that I hadn't heard of that sounded like sort of similar to pneumonia. Oh, okay. Yeah. But is something treatable with antibiotics likely today? How old was he? I don't know, Angela, I'm sorry. What was the name of the disease? How old was he? Okay, okay, okay, okay. Okay, what's fast fact number two?
我们明白了。正是如此。所以本·富兰克林是一位多产的发明家，你知道，空中的风筝等等。是的。然后他死于一种在今天可以用抗生素治疗的疾病。他死于什么？嗯，有些人认为他死于梅毒的并发症，但他死于一种我没听说过的疾病，听起来有点像肺炎。哦，好吧。是的。但这是今天可以用抗生素治疗的东西吗？他多大了？我不知道，安吉拉，对不起。那种疾病的名字是什么？他多大了？好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧。好吧，快速事实二是什么？
Fast fact number two is Andy Daly the outstanding comedic actor who played Ben Franklin in this episode. Yes. Are you going to tell him what we got? We got some audio clips. And they're so good. He is so funny. Jen and I love these, Andy. Thank you for sending them in.
快速事实二是在这一集中扮演本·富兰克林的杰出喜剧演员安迪·戴利。是的。你要告诉他我们得到了什么吗？我们得到了一些音频片段。它们太棒了。他太搞笑了。珍娜和我喜欢这些，安迪。谢谢你寄来它们。
Here's the thing. You might know Andy Daly from Veep, Reno 911, Modern Family, Comedy Bang Bang, Eastbound, and Down. He studied and performed improv with the Upright Citizens Brigade. We have a very interesting little thing in common, Andy and I. What? Both of our first television credits were for Spin City. Wait, is Spin City with Charlie Sheen? Well, I did the Charlie Sheen one, but he did the Michael J. Fox one.
事情是这样的。你可能从《副总统》、《雷诺911》、《摩登家庭》、《喜剧大爆炸》、《东行漫步》中认识安迪·戴利。他在正直公民旅剧团学习并表演即兴表演。我和安迪有一个非常有趣的共同点。什么？我们俩的第一个电视作品都是《旋转城市》。等等，是查理·辛的那部《旋转城市》吗？嗯，我演的是查理·辛那部，但他演的是迈克尔·J·福克斯那部。
Oh, right. There were two. Yeah. Well, guys, we asked Andy how he got his role in the office, and he said he got it the old-fashioned way. He auditioned for Allison Jones, our casting director. But he had a funny story about his audition and first meeting Allison. Here's what he had to say. Hello, this is Andy Daly, aing your cues about Ben Franklin.
哦，对了。有两个。是的。好吧，伙计们，我们问安迪他是怎么得到《办公室》里的角色的，他说他是用老式的方法得到的。他为我们的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯试镜。但他有一个关于他的试镜和第一次见到艾莉森的有趣故事。这是他要说的。你好，我是安迪·戴利，关于本·富兰克林的线索。
Here's my funny story about Allison Jones. When the UCB Theater opened in Los Angeles, we were doing ASCAT every Saturday and Sunday. night that's a fully improvised long form show long form improv show and i was in it every saturday and sunday and we acquired a superfan this a woman who was just seemed to be at almost every show and we got to talking to her a little bit during the show and a little bit after the show and she just seemed like such a sweet nice lady who was just a real like improv superfan and then um i got an audition for this role of benjamin franklin in the office and i went to the audition, and the casting director was that lady. So I've always said that that speaks so well of
这是我关于艾莉森·琼斯的有趣故事。当UCB剧院在洛杉矶开业时，我们每周六和周日晚上都在做ASCAT，那是一个完全即兴的长篇表演，我每周六和周日都在里面，我们获得了一个超级粉丝，一个似乎几乎每场演出都在的女人，我们在演出期间和演出后和她聊了一点，她看起来就像一个如此甜美、友善的女士，只是一个真正的即兴表演超级粉丝，然后，嗯，我得到了《办公室》里本杰明·富兰克林这个角色的试镜，我去试镜了，选角导演就是那位女士。所以我一直说这说明了
Allison Jones that she is like somebody who goes out to shows and is a comedy fan, and that's why she is the greatest casting director, probably in town for comedies. She casts all your favorite comedies, and that's why. Okay, but yes, I audition. And by the way, when I got that audition for Ben Franklin, I thought, well, I'm going to go, because why not? I got nothing better to do, but they'll never hire me to play Ben Franklin because I was in my mid-30s and in the shape of my life. I mean, I'm like, I got a swimmer's body, no matter. But I figured they're going to hire somebody, some middle-aged, ponchy, bald dude, right? Wouldn't you think?
艾莉森·琼斯非常好，她就像那种会去看演出并且是喜剧迷的人，这就是为什么她是城里最好的喜剧选角导演，可能。她选了你所有最喜欢的喜剧，这就是原因。好吧，但是是的，我试镜了。顺便说一句，当我得到那个本·富兰克林的试镜时，我想，好吧，我会去的，因为为什么不呢？我没什么更好的事可做，但他们永远不会雇我演本·富兰克林，因为我当时30多岁，正处于我一生中最好的状态。我的意思是，我像，我有一个游泳者的身体，没关系。但我以为他们会雇佣某个人，某个中年、大腹便便、秃顶的家伙，对吧？你难道不这么认为吗？
But I was like, well, I'll go anyway and I'll do my best. And so, and that has happened to me with so many of the rules that I've gotten. And I have gone just for the hell of it, even thinking they'll never hire me for this. I'm all wrong for it. And I'm so glad that I was wrong. It was a fun audition and I was surprised to get the part, surprised, but delighted. There you go. I love that Allison Jones was just going to all of those shows.
但我当时想，好吧，我还是会去，我会尽我所能。所以，这发生在我得到的这么多角色中。我只是为了好玩而去，甚至认为他们永远不会因为这个雇佣我。我完全不适合它。我很高兴我错了。那是一次有趣的试镜，我很惊讶能得到这个角色，惊讶，但很高兴。给你。我喜欢艾莉森·琼斯会去看所有那些演出。
I just love it. I think she still does. And all of you aspiring actors out there, go to every audition. You don't know what they're looking for. Why not you? That's what I always say. Yeah, why not you? Don't psych yourself out of a part.
我只是喜欢它。我想她现在还在做。你们所有有抱负的演员，去参加每一次试镜。你不知道他们在寻找什么。为什么不是你？这就是我一直说的。是的，为什么不是你？不要让自己因为心理作用而放弃一个角色。
Yeah. Well, I love that. What's your fast fact number three? Well, before we move on to fast fact number three, we have a fan question from Morgan McLeod. I need to know more about Elizabeth the Stripper. She is amazing. And I love how she reprises her role in a few more episodes.
是的。好吧，我喜欢那个。你的快速事实三是什么？嗯，在我们进入快速事实三之前，我们有一个来自摩根·麦克劳德的粉丝问题。我需要更多地了解脱衣舞娘伊丽莎白。她太棒了。我喜欢她在更多剧集中重演她的角色。
How did she get cast for this role? Well, guys, her name is Jackie DeBotten. She is so funny. She's so funny. She's so perfect. Oh, my God. Well, we tried to get in touch with her because we really wanted Jackie to send in audio clips too. But Jackie, I don't think you check your Instagram very often because the next time you go on there, you're going to have a sweet DM from Ms. Angela Kinsey, just waiting for you.
她是怎么得到这个角色的？好吧，伙计们，她的名字是杰基·德博滕。她太搞笑了。她太搞笑了。她太完美了。哦，我的天哪。嗯，我们试图联系她，因为我们真的很想让杰基也寄来音频片段。但杰基，我不认为你经常查看你的Instagram，因为下次你上去的时候，你会收到一条来自安吉拉·金赛女士的甜蜜私信，就在那里等着你。
Well, listen, Jackie, someday you're going to see that DM from me and you have two more episodes and we would love to talk to you. So hit us up. Yes, Jackie comes back for fun run and the finale. I reached out to Allison Jones about Jackie, and she told me that Jackie auditioned for the role in Los Angeles was fantastic, was kind of known in the comedy circles here. She has since moved to New York and still works a bunch there. So that's what she's up to. If you're friends with Jackie DeBotten and you hear this, tell her to check her DMs. Yeah, tell her to hit me up.
好吧，听着，杰基，总有一天你会看到我发的那条私信，你还有两集，我们很想和你谈谈。所以联系我们。是的，杰基回来参加了“趣味跑”和结局。我联系了艾莉森·琼斯关于杰基的事，她告诉我杰基在洛杉矶试镜了这个角色，非常棒，在当地的喜剧圈子里很有名。她后来搬到了纽约，在那里仍然工作很多。所以这就是她的近况。如果你是杰基·德博滕的朋友，你听到了这个，告诉她去查看她的私信。是的，告诉她联系我。
All right. Now, fast fact number three. Fast fact number three is that we shot this episode. in January. And it was our first episode back after taking a very long holiday break hiatus. And over that break, Angela, do you remember we got nominated for our first Screen Actors Guild Award? I remember we were so excited. Guys, here's the thing about the Screen Actors Guild Awards. It's actors nominating other actors for their work, their body of work. And if you win as a cast, everyone gets an award. That is not the case with the Emmys. The Emmys only producers get the award. So like even when we won as a cast, we didn't get one. And this was really just like this great, amazing thing for us as a cast to be able to be celebrated like that. Yes. And I guess we were all in a very good mood because when we asked Andy Daly if he had any favorite memories from his time on the show, this is what he mentioned. It would be hard to say that I have a one
好吧。现在，快速事实三。快速事实三是我们拍摄这一集是在一月。这是我们经过很长的假期休息后回来的第一集。在那个假期里，安吉拉，你还记得我们获得了第一个美国演员工会奖提名吗？我记得我们太兴奋了。伙计们，关于美国演员工会奖，事情是这样的。这是演员提名其他演员的工作，他们的作品集。如果你作为一个剧组获胜，每个人都会得到一个奖项。艾美奖的情况并非如此。艾美奖只有制片人才能获得奖项。所以即使我们作为一个剧组获胜，我们也没有得到一个。这对于我们作为一个剧组能够以这种方式被庆祝来说，真的只是像这样伟大、令人惊奇的事情。是的。我想我们当时心情都很好，因为当我们问安迪·戴利他是否有在节目中度过的最喜欢的记忆时，他提到了这一点。很难说我有一个
specific favorite memory. But I will tell you that the week that I was there, something was going on, like the entire cast was maybe going to the SAG Awards or something like that. And everybody was just really excited and in a good mood. And there was a lot of talk of dresses and tuxedos and hair and makeup getting done for some big event. And I was just really delighted by what a positive, happy mood everybody seemed to be in and what fun everybody in the regular cast seemed to be having every day, getting along very well with each other. You know, you end up on sets where there's different kinds of attitudes towards the work and the schedule and the co-workers, but this was one where everybody seemed so happy
特定的最喜欢的记忆。但我会告诉你，我在那里的那一周，发生了一些事情，比如整个剧组可能要去参加演员工会奖之类的。每个人都真的很兴奋，心情很好。有很多关于礼服、燕尾服、头发和化妆的讨论，为了某个大活动。我被每个人似乎都处于那种积极、快乐的心情所打动，常规剧组里的每个人似乎每天都在享受乐趣，彼此相处得很好。你知道，你最终会出现在那种对工作、时间表和同事有不同态度的片场，但这一个每个人似乎都如此快乐，
and to really realize how lucky they were to be on such a great, well-written show that it was so much fun to do. So just in general, the spirit and the incredible welcoming-welcomingness. I know that's not a word. But everybody was just so welcoming and happy. It was a very lovely week. That's all. I love that. Lady, I wrote about this in my journal.
并且真正意识到他们是多么幸运能参加这样一个伟大、写得很好的节目，做起来太有趣了。所以总的来说，那种精神和令人难以置信的欢迎——欢迎感。我知道那不是一个词。但每个人都非常热情和快乐。那是非常可爱的一周。就是这样。我喜欢那个。女士，我在我的日记里写过这个。
The Screen Actors Guild came by. are set to present us with our official nomination certificates for best ensemble for comedy. E. stopped by with their cameras and interviewed a few of us as well. When Phyllis looked at her certificate, she began to tear up. And then I began to tear up watching her. The SAG Awards are January 28th. I really hope we win. And we did. And we did. We won. It was such an amazing thing. It was just, just magical and just such a celebration for our cast. Oh, I remember when the certificate guy came to. It felt super official.
演员工会来到我们的片场，为我们颁发了最佳喜剧群戏的官方提名证书。E.也顺便带着他们的摄像机采访了我们中的几个人。当菲利斯看着她的证书时，她开始流泪。然后我看着她也开始流泪。演员工会奖是在1月28日。我真的希望我们能赢。我们赢了。我们赢了。那真是太神奇了。那只是，只是神奇，对我们的剧组来说真是一场庆祝。哦，我记得证书发放员来的时候。感觉超级正式。
I didn't know they did that. I didn't know they did it either. And I think we were just sort of all taken by surprise. And then just watching Phyllis hold that in her hands and watching the emotion go over her face. I remember it. It was, it was really just such a tender moment to share. I love that you wrote about it, and I love that you told us. And I think that makes it a good place to, we can take a break.
我不知道他们会那样做。我也不知道他们会那样做。我想我们都被吓了一跳。然后看着菲利斯把那个拿在手里，看着情绪在她的脸上流露。我记得。那，那真的只是一个如此温柔的时刻。我喜欢你写了它，我喜欢你告诉我们。我认为这让它成为一个好地方，我们可以休息一下。
All right, lady, we'll come back and break down this episode. Love it. Hey, we know you probably hit play to escape your business banking, not think about it. But what if we told you there was a way to skip over the pressures of banking? By matching with a TD Small Business Account Manager, you can get the proactive business banking advice, and support your business needs. Ready to press play? Get up to $2,700 when you open
好吧，女士，我们会回来解析这一集。喜欢它。嘿，我们知道你可能点击播放是为了逃避你的商业银行事务，而不是去想它。但如果我们告诉你有一种方法可以跳过银行业务的压力呢？通过与TD小企业客户经理匹配，你可以获得主动的商业银行建议，并支持你的企业需求。准备好点击播放了吗？当你开设
select small business banking products. Yep, that's $2,700 to turn up your business. Visit TD.com slash small business match to learn more. Conditions apply. Risk is the podcast where people tell true stories they never thought they dare to share like our episode After All,
精选小企业银行产品时，获得高达2,700美元。是的，那是2,700美元来提升你的业务。访问TD.com斜杠小企业匹配以了解更多。条件适用。风险是播客，人们讲述他们从未想过敢于分享的真实故事，比如我们的剧集《毕竟》，
where Ken Cole and Tom Ballet share about the night their son had a psychotic. break. And at that point, I didn't actually know I had been stabbed all over my arm. I was in shock. Find the risk episode after all on the free Odyssey app or wherever you get your podcasts. All right. So now we're in the episode. It's the cold open. Michael has decided he wants to make a video for his future son. Dwight is filming him. here was what happened. Michael had a near-death experience. I guess he was cleaning some gunk off the wall sockets of his condo, but he was using a fork. Yeah, he was using a metal fork. Michael. Michael, anyway, this led him to have an epiphery. Life is short, people. Wait, we had a fan question
肯·科尔和汤姆·芭蕾分享了他们儿子精神崩溃的那天晚上。在那一点上，我实际上不知道我的整个手臂都被刺伤了。我处于休克状态。在免费的Odyssey应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方找到风险剧集《毕竟》。好吧。所以现在我们在剧集中。这是冷开场。迈克尔决定他想为他未来的儿子制作一个视频。德怀特在拍摄他。这里发生了什么。迈克尔有一次濒死体验。我想他当时正在清理他公寓墙壁插座上的一些污垢，但他用的是叉子。是的，他用的是金属叉子。迈克尔。迈克尔，总之，这导致他有了一个“顿悟”（epiphery）。生活是短暂的，人们。等等，我们有一个粉丝问题
from Keisha Heath, who wants to know, was I had an epiphery in the script? Yes, it was. Steve's delivery is flawless. Brilliant. Yes. Well, Jenna, I wrote a few things, just overarching things about this whole episode. Here are three of them, ready? All right. Jenna was sick this week. I was. You can totally hear it. Yeah. Jenna had a cold. Um, where's Oscar? Yes. Yes. And then number three, the season of the Fluffy Blouse. Is this your third Fluffy Blouse? It's my third Fluffy Blouse. We'll get to it. I I have a background catch we'll have to talk about. All right. So now we're in the episode.
来自凯莎·希思，她想知道，“我有一个顿悟”在脚本里吗？是的，它是。史蒂夫的表达是完美的。辉煌。是的。好吧，珍娜，我写了一些东西，关于这一整集的总体情况。这里有三个，准备好了吗？好吧。珍娜这周生病了。我是。你完全听得出来。是的。珍娜感冒了。嗯，奥斯卡在哪里？是的。是的。然后第三，蓬松衬衫的季节。这是你的第三件蓬松衬衫吗？这是我的第三件蓬松衬衫。我们会讲到的。我有一个背景捕捉，我们必须谈谈。好吧。所以现在我们在剧集中。
Yes. And Michael is addressing the group because it is six days before Phyllis's wedding to Bob Vance. He wants everyone to get their hair did. He tells Karen, maybe she should consider investing in a dress or a skirt. Michael says, guys, this might be Phyllis's only wedding and he wants to make sure everybody looks great. so he is instituting prima nocta, which Jim then explains in his talking head is something from the movie Braveheart where the king is allowed to deflower every new bride on her wedding night. So Jenna, here's the thing.
是的。迈克尔正在向小组讲话，因为距离菲利斯和鲍勃·万斯的婚礼还有六天。他希望每个人都把头发做好。他告诉凯伦，也许她应该考虑投资一件裙子或短裙。迈克尔说，伙计们，这可能是菲利斯的唯一一场婚礼，他想确保每个人看起来都很棒。所以他正在实行“初夜权”（prima nocta），吉姆随后在他的谈话头中解释说，这是电影《勇敢的心》里的东西，国王被允许在每个新娘的婚礼之夜夺走她的贞操。所以珍娜，事情是这样的。
Prima noctica was a myth. There's actually no historical evidence that this ever happened. According to the internet, this was just something. that was literary. And I did a deep dive on Reddit, guys. In I-D-J-E-T, that's the handle, they wrote this. Premonautus did not exist as any feudal right or custom. There are a handful of mentions of it in medieval sources, but they're all literary, not historical. It's a myth that developed after the Middle Ages. In 19th century, French historians interested in creating a negative portrayal of the Dark Ages for their own political
初夜权是一个神话。实际上没有历史证据表明这曾经发生过。根据互联网，这只是某种文学上的东西。我在Reddit上做了一次深入研究，伙计们。在I-D-J-E-T，那是用户名，他们写了这个。初夜权并不作为任何封建权利或习俗存在。在中世纪的资料中有少数提到它，但它们都是文学上的，而不是历史上的。这是一个在中世纪之后发展的神话。19世纪，对为自己的政治原因创造对黑暗时代的负面描述感兴趣的法国历史学家，从中创造了一个习俗，并给它起了一个拉丁名字，从而使它变得真实。初夜权概念发展的实际历史比概念本身更迷人，因为它告诉我们很多关于历史学家如何将偏见带入他们的来源和观点。我发现这很迷人。谁写历史，谁就写历史？是的，这就是为什么女性和有色人种在历史书中缺失的原因。并不是我们没有贡献，大家。而是我们没有机会把它写下来。对。
reasons created a custom out of it and gave it a Latin name, thus making it real. The actual history of the development of the idea of premonautus is way more fascinating than the idea itself because it tells us a lot about how historians bring biases to their sources and opinions. I found that fascinating. Who writes the history writes the history? Yes, this is why women and people of color are missing from the history books. It's not that we weren't contributing, y'all. It's that we didn't get to write it down. Right.
别人把它写下来了。非常感谢，离开我的肥皂箱。好吧。我在那里度过了一段愉快的时光。是的。I-D-J-E-T继续说，巴罗有一个非常令人震惊的调查。是艾伦·巴罗写的。它叫《领主的初夜》，神话，哦，珍娜，我要糟蹋这个法语了。
Someone else wrote it down. Thank you so much, leaving my soapbox. Okay. I enjoyed my time there. Yes. I-D-J-E-T goes on to say there is a really astonishing investigation by Barrow. It's by Alan Barrow. It's called the Lord's First Night, the myth of, oh, Jenna, I'm going to butcher this French.
Dray de corsage。你知道那是什么意思吗？Doat意味着权利，嗯，它意味着某种权利。准备好了吗？它意味着大腿的权利。大腿的权利，就像女人的大腿。Duquesneur？是的。
Dray de corsage And do you know what that means? Doat means right, well, it means right of something. Ready? It means right of the thigh. Right of the thigh, like the woman's thigh. Duquesneur? Yes.
所以这一切都始于法国，这个神话。他们想让中世纪看起来很糟糕。他们想让他们那种历史、宗教、故事看起来更优越。所以他们试图让中世纪的英国和苏格兰看起来更野蛮，这样法国人看起来就更进化了，根据这篇文章。所以他们首先称它为……首先他们称它为大腿的权利。
So it started all in France, this myth. They wanted to make medieval times look bad. They wanted their sort of history, their religion, their story to seem superior. So they were trying to make medieval England and Scotland seem more barbaric so that the French would seem more evolved, according to this article. So they first called it... First they called it right of the thigh.
然后他们把它改成了领主的权利。然后它被翻译成拉丁语为初夜权。初夜权。所以给你，伙计们。没有历史支持这曾经发生过。它在文学中被提到，它是一个神话，但它是法国重写历史的一部分。伙计们，你们不能说你们今天听这个播客没有学到东西。你们不能那样做。不。而且你知道吗？还有更多要来的。我有一个关于女子乐队的深入研究即将到来。哦。你会发现原因。女士，我有一个关于毛衣褶皱的深入研究。所以你就等着吧。好吧，继续前进，让我们进入会议室。派对策划委员会正在为菲利斯的午餐淋浴派对做准备。迈克尔进来吹嘘他也在仓库里举办派对。这不是同性恋，但这是一个有男士参加的下午淋浴派对。嗯。嗯。
Then they changed it to right of the Lord. And then it got translated into Latin as prima noctus. Prima nocta. So there you go, guys. There is no history to support that this ever... happened. It was mentioned in literature and it was a myth, but it was part of the French rewriting history. Guys, you cannot say that you did not learn things from listening to this podcast today. You can't do it. No. And you know what? There is more to come. I've got a deep
每次你走进房间，史蒂夫都会对我们说不同的东西。这里有精彩的NG镜头。因为我们一直在笑。我们笑得太厉害了，但他们选了，怎么了？我的斯彭斯。但这个场景有很多很棒的删减片段。好吧，然后我们发现凯伦和吉姆之间有麻烦。是的。
dive on a girl band coming up. Oh. You'll find out why. Lady, I have a deep dive on a sweater dimple. So you just wait. Well, moving on, let's go into the conference room. The party planning committee is setting up for Phyllis's luncheon shower. And Michael comes in to brag that he is also having a party in the warehouse. It's not gay, but it is an afternoon shower with guys. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
他们一直在进行很多深夜谈话。很多。长，长，长，深夜谈话。哦，安吉拉，这把我带回去了。它带入了这些关系。哦，天哪，我也是。我也是。当凯伦说，我们需要谈谈。
Every time you walked into the room, Steve would say something different to us. There are fantastic bloopers from this. because we kept laughing. We were laughing so hard, but they picked, what's up? My Spence does. But there is a lot of great outtakes from this scene. Well, then we find out that there is trouble between Karen and Jim. Yeah.
我们需要谈谈。他们两个的谈话头都写得太好了。我觉得敏迪当时可能写了一点她自己的生活。但当凯伦被迫站起来走过去给吉姆一个拥抱，就像那个令人安心的拥抱时，我就想，哦，天哪。是的。她说，我们没关系。我们很好。是的，帕姆注意到了。
They've been having a lot of late night talks. A lot. Long, long, long, late night talks. Oh, Angela, this took me back. It took in these relationships. Oh my God, me too. Me too. When Karen was like, we need to have a talk.
是的。她说，吉姆和凯伦之间有些奇怪。帕姆说她已经非常擅长阅读他的脖子后面了。嗯。所以帕姆意识到那里可能有一点麻烦。是的。是的。然后，伙计们，托德·帕克出现了。
We need to talk. Both of their talking heads are so well written. And I feel like Mindy was probably writing a little bit of her life at this time. But also when Karen is compelled to get up and go over and just give Jim a hug, just like that reassuring hug, I was like, oh gosh. Yeah. She's like, we're okay. We're good. Yeah, Pam notices.
他进来时状态非常罕见。是的，他发现吉姆和凯伦在约会。他简直不敢相信。嗯。然后他看到了我。迈克尔，他们做了整个奇怪的动作，包括他像假装踢迈克尔的脸。是的。太棒了。在5分13秒，我有一个打喷嚏的捕捉。你打喷嚏了吗？我在这个场景的背景里打喷嚏。克里斯·罗宾逊和阿纳亚斯·内瑟索尔也注意到了这一点。
Yeah. She's like, there's something weird with Jim and Karen. Pam says she's gotten really good at reading the back of his neck. Mm-hmm. So Pam is aware there might be a little trouble there. Yeah. Yeah. And then, guys, Todd Packer makes an appearance.
珍娜，我在YouTube上看到了你在片场打喷嚏的蒙太奇。你看过吗？是的。我过去打喷嚏打得太多了。你有非常严重的过敏。我觉得片场有什么东西让你过敏。好吧，每次他们移动我桌子上的灯时，天花板上的所有颗粒都会掉到我的桌子上。所以真的很脏。然后他们开始做这件美妙的事情，他们会像戴尔，他是我们的场务之一，会过来，他会用羽毛掸子帮我掸掉桌子上的灰尘，因为打喷嚏的问题，这给声音和摄像造成了问题。所以，但是是的，我想这是在我们开始掸我桌子上的灰尘之前，因为早期的几季，我打喷嚏很多。是的，你打，你打。很多。所以现在我们在
He comes in and is just in rare form. Yeah, he finds out that Jim and Karen are dating. He can't believe it. Mm-mm. And then he sees me. Michael, and they do this whole weird bit that involves him like fake kicking Michael in the face. Yeah. It was amazing. At five minutes, 13 seconds, I have a sneeze catch. Did you sneeze? I sneeze in the background of this scene. It was also noticed by Chris Robinson and Anayas Nethersole.
迈克尔的办公室里，迈克尔正在告诉托德关于下午单身派对的事。托德·帕克太沮丧了。他有一天的销售电话。他太生气了。他开始折断铅笔。他说，我不能来。哦，我们有一个关于那个的粉丝捕捉，安吉拉。什么？阿丽娜·B说当托德·帕克和迈克尔说话时，托德折断了一支铅笔。但当谈话在他们两人之间来回进行时，你可以看到那个装铅笔的蓝色杯子从有铅笔变成了没有铅笔。这是真的。在场景开始时，他折断了一支铅笔，但在6分04秒，铅笔又回到了杯子里。所以很明显，戴夫·凯克纳做了那个铅笔动作可能不止一次，他们很喜欢，但然后，你知道，他们用了其他拍摄来完成场景的其余部分。
Jenna, I saw a montage of you sneezing on set on YouTube. Have you seen it? Yeah. I used to sneeze so. much. You had really bad allergies. I feel like there was something on the set that you were allergic to. Well, every time they would move the lights above my desk, all of that like particles from the ceiling would fall down on my desk. And so it was really dusty. And then they started doing this wonderful thing where they would come like Dale, who like was one of our grips would come over and he would like feather duster my desk off for me because of the sneezing problem, which was causing problems for sound and camera. So, but yes, I think this was before we started dusting my desk because the early seasons, I sneeze a lot. Yeah, you do, you do. A lot. So now we're
我觉得那是一个很好的捕捉。干得好，阿丽娜。那是一个很棒的捕捉。好吧，托德问迈克尔，你知道，好吧，你雇脱衣舞娘了吗？迈克尔说，什么？不，不。然后他说，你对策划单身派对一无所知。这会很烂。你必须有一个脱衣舞娘。你去过吗？迈克尔说，是的。嗯，不，不是真的。不是亲自。从来没有。你知道我的意思吗？就像，迈克尔在很多方面真的很天真。好吧，所以托德说服他，他需要为女士们雇一个脱衣舞娘。因为那意味着他可以为男士们雇一个脱衣舞娘。迈克尔就像，他的大脑被震撼了。他说，哦，天哪，是的。我想说迈克尔计划的那个45分钟的小派对，减去脱衣舞娘，听起来真的很可爱。是的。听起来真的很有趣。牛排和牌。是的。牛排和牌。在你的工作日中多么有趣，多么有趣的休息。是的。然后托德不得不让它变得奇怪。好吧，这就是托德做的。这就是托德做的。所以迈克尔走进办公室。他宣布男女混用的裸体脱衣舞娘将来到办公室。哦，安吉拉，你和梅雷迪思之间的这段交流，让我大声笑出来。
in Michael's office and Michael is telling Todd about the afternoon bachelor party. And Todd Packer is so bummed. He has a day of sales calls. He's so ticked. He starts breaking pencils. He's like, I can't come. Oh, we have a fan catch about that, Angela. What? Alina B. said when Todd Packer is talking to Michael, Todd breaks a pencil. But as the conversation goes back and forth between the two of them, you can see that the blue mug that holds the pencils goes from having pencils in it to no pencils in it. And it's true. At the top of the scene, he breaks a pencil, but then at six minutes, four seconds, the pencils are back in the cup. So clearly, Dave Kekner did that pencil bit probably one of many times and they loved it, but then, you know, they used other takes for the rest of the
凯特和我为粉丝们重演过几次。安吉拉开口了，你说什么，安吉拉？我说类似，在任何情况下，男人都不应该在办公室脱衣服。然后梅雷迪思就像，闭嘴，安吉拉！它从无处而来。它从无处而来。太疯狂了。就像，释放海怪。
scene. I thought that was such a good catch. Good job, Alina. That is a great catch. Well, Todd asked Michael, you know, well, did you get a stripper? And Michael's like, what? No, no. And then he's like, you don't know anything about planning a bachelor party. It's going to suck. You got to have a stripper. Have you ever been to one? And Michael's like, yes. Well, no, not really. Not in person. Never. You know what I mean? Like, Michael is really just so innocent in so many ways. Well, so Todd convinces him that he needs to hire a stripper for the women. Because then that means he can hire a stripper for the men. And Michael is like, his mind is blown. He's like, oh my gosh, yes. I want to say the little 45. minute party that Michael had planned, minus the stripper, sounded really lovely. Yeah. It actually sounded like fun. Steak and cards. Yeah. Steak and cards. What a fun, what a fun like break in your work day. Yeah. And then Todd had to make it weird. Well, that's what Todd does. That's what Todd does. So Michael walks into the office. He announces that co-ed naked strippers will be coming to the office. Oh, Angela, this exchange between you and Meredith, it makes me laugh out loud.
而且就像梅雷迪思，你知道。太吵闹、刺耳，而且只是生气。是她吗？这就像她在这一整集中唯一的台词之一。好吧，那之后，她当然就像，等等，这就是脱衣舞娘。是的，正是如此。但这是我的背景捕捉，在6分38秒，就在梅雷迪思大喊“闭嘴，安吉拉”时。我把头甩过肩膀。
Kate and I have reenacted this a few times for fans. Angela speaks up, and what do you say, Angela? I say something like, under no circumstance, should a man take off his clothes at the office? And then Meredith is like, shit it up, Angela! It goes from nowhere. It comes out of nowhere. It was so crazy. It was like, release the Kraken.
凯特和我为粉丝们重演过几次这一幕。安吉拉开口了，安吉拉，你说了什么？我说了一些类似“无论如何，男人都不应该在办公室脱衣服”的话。然后梅雷迪思就说，闭嘴，安吉拉！这简直莫名其妙。它来得太突然了。太疯狂了。就像是释放了海怪一样。
And it's like Meredith, you know. It's so loud and abrasive and just angry. Is it her? It's like one of her only lines in this whole episode. Well, that and then she, of course, is like, wait, this is the stripper. Yes, exactly. But here is my background catch at six minutes, 38 seconds, right as Meredith yells, shut up, Angela. I whip my head over my shoulder.
这就是梅雷迪思，你知道的。声音又大又刺耳，而且非常愤怒。是她吗？这好像是她整集里仅有的几句台词之一。嗯，还有就是，当然，她说，等等，这是脱衣舞男。没错，就是这样。但在六分三十八秒时，也就是梅雷迪思大喊“闭嘴，安吉拉”的时候，我有一个背景捕捉，我猛地转过头看向肩膀那边。
I'm standing at the copier. This is a great photo moment of my whole outfit with the flufy collar. But guys, I want you to know, six minutes, 38 seconds, you can see a sweater bump. A sweater bump? What's a sweater bump? What is that? This moment really brought me back, Jenna, because wardrobe had hung my sweater on a hanger. And when I went to put that sweater on over my fluffy blouse that morning, I had these two weird pointy-outy things
我正站在复印机旁。这可是我全身穿着毛绒领衣服的绝佳拍照时刻。但伙计们，我想让你们知道，在6分38秒时，你们能看到一个“毛衣凸起”。毛衣凸起？什么是毛衣凸起？那是什么？珍娜，这一刻真的让我回想起了过去，因为服装组把我的毛衣挂在衣架上。那天早上，当我把那件毛衣套在我的毛绒衬衫外面时，我的肩膀上出现了两个奇怪的尖尖的东西，
over my shoulders where the hangar was on my sweater. Right. And I walked on set and wardrobe was like, oh no, oh no. And they were trying to like, it would look so weird. They were trying to get them out. We couldn't get them out. And so I was trying to figure out how to tell you this story. And I looked up sweater bump on shoulder thingy.
就在衣架挂着毛衣的地方。没错。我走进片场时，服装组的人说，哦不，哦不。他们试图，因为看起来太奇怪了。他们试图把它们弄平。我们没法弄平。所以我一直在想怎么给你们讲这个故事。我查了“毛衣凸起”和“肩膀上的东西”。
What is this called, Jenna? It has a name? It has several. Depending on where you live. These are called hangar bumps. sweater bumps, sweater shoulder nipples, sweater dimple. And I went to she finds.com and they're like, listen, you need to fold your sweaters. But if you have to hang your sweater, you need to fold it in half and drape it over the bottom
这叫什么，珍娜？它有名字吗？它有好几个名字。取决于你住在哪里。这些被称为“衣架凸起”、“毛衣凸起”、“毛衣肩膀乳头”、“毛衣酒窝”。我去了shefinds.com，他们说，听着，你需要折叠你的毛衣。但如果你必须挂毛衣，你需要把它对折，然后搭在衣架的底部。
of the hanger. But guess what? There are now special hangers for sweaters that you might have to hang that won't give you shoulder bumps and luxury living bumps be gone extra long hang. is made a flexible foam, guys, if you have a sweater to hang up and you don't want to look weird at work with your, I don't know, your sweater bumps, your hanger bumps, your sweater dimple, it's an option. All I can think during all of this is why you have not consistently referred to them as shoulder
但你猜怎么着？现在有专门为毛衣设计的衣架，你可能需要挂起来，这样就不会有肩膀凸起和奢侈生活凸起。超长挂架是用柔性泡沫制成的，伙计们，如果你有一件毛衣要挂起来，而且你不想在工作中看起来很奇怪，带着你的，我不知道，你的毛衣凸起，你的衣架凸起，你的毛衣酒窝，这是一个选择。在这一切过程中，我唯一能想到的就是为什么你没有一直称它们为“肩膀
nipples. No, that was my favorite one. Sweater, shoulder nipples. Sweater shoulder nipples. You have to say the word sweater, sweater, shoulder nipples. Sweeter shoulder nipples. Jenna, I took a picture of it to show you. It is hilarious.
乳头”。不，那是我最喜欢的。毛衣，肩膀乳头。毛衣肩膀乳头。你必须说出“毛衣”这个词，毛衣，肩膀乳头。毛衣肩膀乳头。珍娜，我拍了一张照片给你看。太搞笑了。
It brought me back. I was laughing so hard because I remember walking on set and then being like, oh, no. Like, what happened? Look, I can't wait to show you. Oh, no. It's so, it looks like my shoulder has a nipple. It is. You guys, I'm so sad you can't see the picture that Angela just showed us, but we will put it on Office Ladies Pod Instagram.
这让我想起了过去。我笑得太厉害了，因为我记得走进片场，然后说，哦，不。就像，发生了什么？看，我迫不及待想给你看。哦，不。太，看起来我的肩膀长了一个乳头。确实是。伙计们，我很遗憾你们看不到安吉拉刚才给我们看的照片，但我们会把它放在Office Ladies Pod的Instagram上。
We have to remember. I promise, Jenna. We'll put it on Office Ladies' Pod. I remember I was texting Jenna when we were working. working on this, and I was like, I have a deep dive you are not going to see coming. And that was it, Jenna. You're welcome. I absolutely loved it. Well, now, I mean, oh, God, this next scene is so awkward. I know. It's so awkward at six minutes, 50 seconds. Pam and Jim are in the break room. And is Pam like trying to bond, but she's flirting, but she doesn't know what to say. It is so
我们必须记住。我保证，珍娜。我们会把它放在Office Ladies' Pod上。我记得我们在工作时给珍娜发短信，我们正在做这个，我说，我有一个你绝对想不到的深度挖掘。就是那个，珍娜。不客气。我绝对喜欢它。好吧，现在，我的意思是，哦，天哪，下一场戏太尴尬了。我知道。在6分50秒时太尴尬了。帕姆和吉姆在休息室。帕姆是在试图拉近关系吗，但她在调情，但她不知道该说什么。这太
cringy. I think she's fishing. I think she's just wants to know what's up. She knows, she knows something's going on. I don't think this is the same as when she helped Jim with the whole like apartment issue. Remember when she was like, listen, I don't think it's a big deal if she lives two blocks away. I think you're, you're overreacting. I felt like in that moment, she was like, you know what, let's move this into a friendship lane and I'm going to be a friend and give you friend advice. This just felt like she was fishing for the gossip to me, but then also trying to be super casual about it, but then also, I don't know, super awkward.
令人尴尬了。我觉得她在试探。我觉得她只是想知道发生了什么。她知道，她知道有什么事情正在发生。我不认为这和她帮吉姆解决公寓问题时一样。还记得她说，听着，我不觉得她住在两个街区外是什么大不了的事。我觉得你，你反应过度了。我觉得在那一刻，她就像是，你知道吗，让我们进入友谊轨道，我要做一个朋友，给你朋友的建议。这对我来说感觉就像她在打听八卦，但同时也试图对此表现得超级随意，但又，我不知道，超级尴尬。
I don't think she was so much fishing for gossip as much as just she wants to know. I think, you know, she probably wouldn't want to admit this to herself. But if there's trouble in paradise there, she, you know, wants to know. But what's she going to do with the information? I'm sorry, we might be moving into wishy-washy-pam territory. We're in wishy-washy-pam because also like, oh, Jenna, your performance is so good. When she's sort of sing-songing, she's like, when I get eight hours compared to like six, it's like big difference. Like you have this.
我不认为她是在打听八卦，更多的是她只是想知道。我想，你知道，她可能不想对自己承认这一点。但如果那里有麻烦，她，你知道，想知道。但她会用这些信息做什么？抱歉，我们可能要进入“优柔寡断的帕姆”领域了。我们正处于“优柔寡断的帕姆”状态，因为还有，哦，珍娜，你的表演太棒了。当她有点像唱歌一样，她说，当我睡八小时对比六小时，就像有很大区别。就像你有这个。
And then she's like, got to get that rip sleep. Don't fall asleep at your desk. And then he's like, okay, Beasley. And you turn around to the vending machine and you're like, oh, you're so annoyed with yourself. All right, well, now we're going to move back into the bullpen. Michael tells Jim to hire a stripper. He's like, I will not. Dwight volunteers and immediately starts working on it.
然后她说，得保证充足的睡眠。别在办公桌前睡着了。然后他说，好的，比斯利。然后你转身走向自动售货机，你就像，哦，你对自己太恼火了。好吧，现在我们要回到办公区。迈克尔告诉吉姆去雇一个脱衣舞娘。他说，我不会。德怀特自告奋勇，并立即开始着手处理。
Dwight gets someone on the phone. And he asked Jim if they should request a redhead or a brunette to which Jim responds blonde. And then Dwight is like, yes. Tons of people. Heather, Rochelle, Gabby, Jamie, Brianna. Steph, Allison, and many more all asked when Dwight asked Jim to choose between a brunette and a redhead stripper. It's implied that Jim feels uncomfortable answering this question because it's like he's deciding between Karen and Pam. Is Pam a redhead?
德怀特接通了一个人的电话。他问吉姆他们应该要求红发还是黑发，吉姆回答说金发。然后德怀特说，是的。很多人。希瑟、罗谢尔、加比、杰米、布里安娜。斯蒂芬妮、艾莉森等等，当德怀特让吉姆在黑发和红发脱衣舞娘之间做出选择时，所有人都问了。暗示吉姆对回答这个问题感到不舒服，因为这就像他在凯伦和帕姆之间做选择。帕姆是红发吗？
Oh! This is the question. And I have seen this question on fan sites before. What color is Pam's hair? Is she a brunette? Is she a redhead? one person wrote my family is very divided on this issue many people said this question has families fiancees and friends divided please tell us what color hair does pam have well your hair's
哦！这就是问题所在。我以前在粉丝网站上见过这个问题。帕姆的头发是什么颜色的？她是黑发吗？她是红发吗？一个人写道，我的家人在这个问题上非常分歧，许多人说这个问题让家庭、未婚夫和朋友们产生了分歧，请告诉我们帕姆的头发是什么颜色，好吧，你的头发是
auburn isn't it yeah it's like a reddish brown you guys i think everyone's right but it did have these reddish tones however i think i shot a movie over our hiatus and in this particular episode my hair was not exactly as red as it was, I think, earlier in the show. So when they wrote this line, I think they were expecting that it would be more obvious that they were talking about me because I did have these reddish hues to my hair. But I think it got changed a little bit because I was shooting something and they took a little of the red out. I think that's the controversy, you guys.
赤褐色，不是吗？是的，就像红棕色，伙计们，我想每个人都对，但它确实有这些红色的色调。然而，我想我在我们的间歇期拍了一部电影，在这一集中，我的头发并不完全像我想的那样，在节目的早期那么红。所以当他们写这句台词时，我想他们预料到他们谈论的是我会更明显，因为我的头发确实有这些红色的色调。但我想它稍微改变了一点，因为我在拍别的东西，他们去掉了红色。我想这就是争议所在，伙计们。
Yeah, I just always have thought of your hair as Auburn. And I felt like in that moment, Jim wasn't taking any chances. Like, it was kind of like a dude moment where he's like, I don't really know what color her hair is. But if I rule out brown and red, I'm safe. So I'll just go blonde. I also have a fan catch from this scene from Hannah, who said at eight minutes, seven seconds, if you look behind Dwight, there is a picture on Phyllis's desk of Creed, Phyllis, and Ryan. Why does Phyllis have a picture on her desk of the three of them? And she does.
是的，我一直认为你的头发是赤褐色的。我觉得在那一刻，吉姆不想冒险。这有点像男人的时刻，他就像，我真的不知道她头发是什么颜色。但如果我排除棕色和红色，我就安全了。所以我还是选金发吧。我还有一个来自汉娜的粉丝发现，她说在8分07秒，如果你看德怀特身后，菲利斯的桌子上有一张克里德、菲利斯和瑞恩的照片。为什么菲利斯的桌子上会有他们三个人的照片？她确实有。
She has a picture of herself and Creed and BJ. Wild. I don't know why, though, but it's so cute. I don't either. I always remembered her photo of her and her dad that she brought in. Yeah. Huh. Yeah.
她有一张她自己、克里德和BJ的照片。太疯狂了。我不知道为什么，但这太可爱了。我也不知道。我一直记得她带进来的那张她和她爸爸的照片。是的。嗯。是的。
Okay. Good catch. Okay. So now Michael and Ryan have left the office to go to a sex shop for this bachelor party. Michael is just giggling nonstop. Well, Michael gets a phone call. It's from Jim. He's letting him know that there are a few options for the male strippers.
好的。好发现。好的。所以现在迈克尔和瑞恩已经离开办公室去性用品商店参加这个单身派对。迈克尔一直在咯咯笑。好吧，迈克尔接到了一个电话。是吉姆打来的。他让他知道男脱衣舞娘有几个选择。
When he gets his phone call, did you recognize his ringtone? What was it? It was, my humps, ma'humps. No, I did not. Buy the black-eyed peas. All right. I like it. Yep. Jim says, listen, Michael referred me to a male strip club called banana slings.
当他接到这个电话时，你认出他的铃声了吗？是什么？是《My Humps》，我的驼峰。不，我没有。黑眼豆豆的。好吧。我喜欢它。是的。吉姆说，听着，迈克尔把我推荐给了一个叫“香蕉吊带”的男脱衣舞俱乐部。
But instead, I called the scholastic speakers of Pennsylvania. Maddie, Becky, and Andrew all wrote in to ask, is banana slings a real place and is Scholastic Speakers of Pennsylvania a real organization that offers a Ben Franklin speaker? Neither of them seemed to be real. I had always thought a banana sling was like a, also like a banana hammock. Isn't that like a male sort of like kind of Euro speedo? I mean, I think it's a good name for a male strip club organization, banana slings. It's like, you know, a lot of men are slinging. Oh, yes.
但我反而给宾夕法尼亚州的学术演讲者打了电话。麦迪、贝基和安德鲁都写信问，“香蕉吊带”是一个真实的地方吗？“宾夕法尼亚州学术演讲者”是一个提供本·富兰克林演讲者的真实组织吗？它们似乎都不是真的。我一直以为“香蕉吊带”就像，也像“香蕉吊床”。那不是一种男式的，有点像欧洲泳裤吗？我的意思是，我觉得这对男脱衣舞俱乐部组织来说是个好名字，“香蕉吊带”。就像，你知道，很多男人在吊着。哦，是的。
They're bananas. So where do we go? Okay, now they're in the elevator. Michael and Ryan are coming back to work. They're in the elevator. Ben Franklin hops in. And Michael's like, are you wearing a thong? And he's like, what?
他们的香蕉。那我们去哪儿？好吧，现在他们在电梯里。迈克尔和瑞恩正要回公司。他们在电梯里。本·富兰克林跳了进来。迈克尔说，你穿的是丁字裤吗？他说，什么？
We had actually asked Andy about his wardrobe and what all he was wearing because it looked like so many different pieces. Yes. And here is what he had to say. One thing I remember from that shoot was that a few days prior to my coming in to shoot for it, I had to come in for a. a fitting. And I thought the entire time that I was at this fitting that I was about
我们实际上问过安迪关于他的服装以及他穿的所有东西，因为它看起来像很多不同的部分。是的。这就是他要说的。我从那次拍摄中记得的一件事是，在我去拍摄的前几天，我不得不去进行一次试装。我在这次试装的整个过程中都以为我快要
to get fired because I thought like they're going to put together a look for me as Ben Franklin and then parade me up to all the producers to Mindy Kaling and all the executive producers which I was told ahead of time was what was going to happen and that somebody was going to look at me and say, no, go
被解雇了，因为我想他们会为我准备一套本·富兰克林的造型，然后把我带到所有制片人、明迪·卡灵和所有执行制片人面前，我提前被告知会发生这种情况，有人会看着我说，不，去
get the middle-aged ponchy bald guy. Like this is not working and particularly since my wig was this ridiculous it really was like a Halloween store bald wig that they then glued it was meant to look cheap they glued hair you know cheap hair around to it I was like this is a definite direction to go in with this but I'm surprised by head it feels real weird and then yes when they did parade me in front of those producers it wasn't like they weren't like yeah awesome they were just kind
找那个中年大腹便便的秃头家伙。这行不通，特别是我的假发太荒谬了，它确实像万圣节商店的秃头假发，他们然后粘上，它本意是看起来很便宜，他们粘上头发，你知道，便宜的头发在周围，我当时想，这绝对是一个方向，但我对头感到惊讶，感觉真的很奇怪，然后是的，当他们把我带到那些制片人面前时，他们并不是说，是的，太棒了，他们只是有点
like uh-huh so I don't know I do remember that the other thing I remember about the costume yes it was elaborate, but to make me look chubby, they gave me a, like a pillow, like a real costume pillow, a pillow from the costume department for the purpose of making someone look fat. And I don't remember if it was right next to my skin or if I had an undershirt in between. It doesn't matter. The point is that if you wear a pillow underneath several layers for like 12 hours, you're going to get a rash on your stomach if you don't use like a baby powder or something like that, which it never occurred to me to use. So that is one of my enduring memories of that shoot, having a
像，嗯哼，所以我不知道，我确实记得关于服装的另一件事，是的，它很精致，但为了让我看起来胖乎乎的，他们给了我一个，像一个枕头，像一个真正的服装枕头，一个来自服装部门的枕头，目的是让人看起来很胖。我不记得它是直接贴着我的皮肤，还是中间有一件内衣。没关系。重点是，如果你在几层衣服下面穿一个枕头大约12个小时，如果你不使用像婴儿爽身粉之类的东西，你的肚子上就会长皮疹，我从来没想过要用。所以这是我对那次拍摄的持久记忆之一，整整一周都有一个
very itchy rash that whole week, sweating as I was underneath that fat pillow. So just a hot tip, baby powder. I think that would have helped. Amazing. Poor guy, you had a rash the whole week. I feel like we should talk with him more because throughout the course of shooting this series, you and I had to wear fake pregnancy bellies. And I feel like the three of us could really go out and have a very like a bonding evening over what it's like. Oh, oh, we could. I remember wearing a tank top under all my layers that would tuck under the fake belly pillow thing to try to protect my body from it rubbing all day. Yeah, because you get a real. thin layer of sweat, and then that sort of breeds an environment that is real rash happy.
非常痒的皮疹，我在那个胖枕头下出汗。所以一个小贴士，婴儿爽身粉。我想那会有帮助。太棒了。可怜的家伙，你整整一周都有皮疹。我觉得我们应该和他多聊聊，因为在拍摄这个系列的过程中，你和我不得不穿假的怀孕肚子。我觉得我们三个人真的可以出去，度过一个非常像，建立感情的夜晚，关于那是什么感觉。哦，哦，我们可以。我记得在所有层衣服下穿一件背心，会塞进假肚子枕头下面，试图保护我的身体不被它整天摩擦。是的，因为你会有一层真正的薄汗，然后这会滋生一种环境，真的很喜欢长皮疹。
It's rash happy. Yeah, it's rash happy. Well, lady, we are in the conference room now. The lady's party is starting. Angela is enjoying sparkling cider. She says it's very good. Yeah, but then Pam tells her, I think that's champagne and she spits it back into her glass. She does, but later she's still drinking it.
它很喜欢皮疹。是的，它很喜欢皮疹。好吧，女士，我们现在在会议室。女士派对开始了。安吉拉正在享受气泡苹果酒。她说非常好。是的，但后来帕姆告诉她，我觉得那是香槟，她把它吐回了杯子里。她确实吐了，但后来她还在喝。
Oh, my gosh. You spotted it, as did Olivia Fitzgerald. That was caught also by Mary N. Ashlyn, Phoebe, Meg, Paige, and Amy. They all pointed out that Angela drinks her champagne again at 11 minutes and 34 seconds. Okay, so after Angela spits her champagne back into her glass, one of my favorite all-time moments ever on the series, Michael brings sexy Ben Franklin in to the room. Everyone is very confused. Every time he walks into that conference room, it makes me laugh.
哦，天哪。你发现了，奥利维亚·菲茨杰拉德也发现了。玛丽·N、阿什琳、菲比、梅格、佩奇和艾米也发现了。她们都指出安吉拉在11分34秒时又喝了她的香槟。好吧，所以安吉拉把香槟吐回杯子后，这是我在该系列中最喜欢的时刻之一，迈克尔把性感的本·富兰克林带进了房间。每个人都很困惑。每次他走进那个会议室，都让我发笑。
Just thinking about it, makes me laugh. Michael tells him that he is giving him permission to spank anyone. Especially Phyllis. Who misbehaves, especially Phyllis. And Phyllis looks a little bit like maybe tickled by the idea. Phyllis is maybe up for it. She might be up for it. She's like, I don't know.
只要想到它，就让我发笑。迈克尔告诉他，他允许他打任何人的屁股。特别是菲利斯。谁表现不好，特别是菲利斯。菲利斯看起来有点，也许被这个想法逗乐了。菲利斯也许愿意。她可能愿意。她就像，我不知道。
I don't know. We'll see where it goes. Yeah. At 10 minutes, 20 seconds, there's an exchange between Ben Franklin and Michael that Andy mentioned was one of his favorite scenes to shoot in addition to a few more that he mentions, but here's what he had to say about doing this scene. This is just another favorite moment that I wanted to share. There's a moment in one of the scenes where Michael Scott asks Ben Franklin something like
我不知道。我们看看会发生什么。是的。在10分20秒时，本·富兰克林和迈克尔之间有一段对话，安迪提到这是他最喜欢拍摄的场景之一，除了他提到的其他几个，但这就是他关于拍摄这场戏的说法。这是我想分享的另一个最喜欢的时刻。在其中一个场景中，迈克尔·斯科特问本·富兰克林一些事情，比如
what year were you president or something like that. And Ben Franklin says, actually, I was never president. And of course, that's true. Ben Franklin was never president of the United States. And then Michael Scott leans in and quietly says, yes, but Ben Franklin was thinking that that's a moment that the actor playing Ben Franklin has dropped character and thinking, you know, the way an idiot thinks other people are stupid that this guy is answering the question, that this actor is saying I was never president. Well, of course this actor was never present. Anyway, why am I explaining the joke? That makes me laugh a great deal and is one of my treasured memories from that shoot. And one of my favorite moments from the episode, along with, of course, the moment when, after all this refusal to drop character, Ben Franklin, or as we come to know him, Gordon, does finally drop character to a flirt.
你哪一年当总统之类的。然后本·富兰克林说，其实，我从来没当过总统。当然，那是真的。本·富兰克林从来没有当过美国总统。然后迈克尔·斯科特凑近，轻声说，是的，但本·富兰克林在想，这是一个扮演本·富兰克林的演员脱离角色的时刻，心想，你知道，白痴认为别人愚蠢的方式，这个家伙在回答问题，这个演员在说我从来没当过总统。好吧，当然这个演员从来没当过总统。总之，我为什么要解释这个笑话？这让我大笑不已，是我对那次拍摄的珍贵记忆之一。也是我这一集中最喜欢的时刻之一，当然，还有那个时刻，在所有这些拒绝脱离角色的行为之后，本·富兰克林，或者我们所知道的戈登，终于脱离了角色去调情。
with Pam and his what he thinks is going to be a flirty come on is to make it clear that he doesn't have syphilis which is not a great pickup line like if that's your pickup line uh you need to work on it because that's that's like the bare minimum requirement i would think for someone that you're going to hook up with uh it's not something to brag about okay that's all thanks bye He made me laugh. Yes. In that scene, he's like, well, Benjamin Franklin was never the president. This made me look up who is on our money, who wasn't a president.
和帕姆，他认为这将是一个调情的搭讪，是明确表示他没有梅毒，这不是一个好的搭讪台词，就像如果那是你的搭讪台词，呃，你需要努力，因为那是，那是，我想对于你要勾搭的人来说，这是最低限度的要求，呃，这不是什么值得吹嘘的事情，好吧，就这样，谢谢，再见。他让我笑了。是的。在那场戏里，他说，嗯，本杰明·富兰克林从来不是总统。这让我查了谁在我们的钱上，谁不是总统。
So there are two. Alexander Hamilton, $10 bill, was not a president. Actually, he wasn't even born in the U.S. How about that? And then Ben Franklin, not a president on the $100 bill. Uh-huh. Then this kind of blew my mind. every person on our paper currency faces to the right except for one man who faces left.
所以有两个。亚历山大·汉密尔顿，10美元纸币，不是总统。其实，他甚至不是在美国出生的。怎么样？然后本·富兰克林，不是100美元纸币上的总统。嗯哼。然后这让我大吃一惊。我们纸币上的每个人都面向右边，除了一个人面向左边。
And that is Alexander Hamilton. Angela is showing me a cartoon drawing called Faces on U.S. currency. Fascinating. This is the greatest podcast ever. I'm sorry. I'm learning so much today. We are now in the parking lot, and the stripper has arrived, Elizabeth, and Dwight is like, identify yourself. And she says, I'm the dancer.
那就是亚历山大·汉密尔顿。安吉拉正在给我看一张名为“美国货币上的人物”的卡通画。太迷人了。这是有史以来最棒的播客。抱歉。我今天学到了很多。我们现在在停车场，脱衣舞娘伊丽莎白到了，德怀特说，表明你的身份。她说，我是舞者。
And Dwight is like, what? I hired a stripper. And she's like, yes, I am the stripper. She's like, it's the same thing, that's what I'm saying. And then Jim is like, have you ever seen his stripper? And Dwight's like, well, kind of, Jennifer Gardner in alias. I don't think he says kind of. He says yes.
德怀特说，什么？我雇了一个脱衣舞娘。她说，是的，我就是脱衣舞娘。她说，是一回事，我就是这么说的。然后吉姆说，你见过脱衣舞娘吗？德怀特说，嗯，有点，詹妮弗·加纳在《双面女间谍》里。我不觉得他说有点。他说是的。
Doesn't he? He's like, of course I have Jennifer Garner on alias. You know, I auditioned for the role of Sidney Bristow on alias and I got really far. Are you kidding? No. Lady. But do you want to go ahead? Could you have done all?
不是吗？他说，我当然见过詹妮弗·加纳在《双面女间谍》里。你知道，我试镜过《双面女间谍》里的悉尼·布里斯托这个角色，我走得很远。你在开玩笑吗？不。女士。但你想继续吗？你能做所有吗？
It was a very athletic role. I'm not saying you're not the most. Are you saying? A person. She had to do all kinds of, like, kicks, flip over things. I mean, it sounds like you are saying I can't do those things, but I will let that go. Because listen to this. This was, okay, so I went in and I read for the role.
这是一个非常运动的角色。我不是说你不是最。你在说什么？一个人。她必须做各种各样的，比如，踢腿，翻转东西。我的意思是，听起来你是在说我做不到那些事情，但我会放过它。因为听听这个。这是，好吧，所以我进去读了这个角色。
And my scene that I had to audition with was this really emotional, dramatic scene where I'm crying, I think, like, about my mother. And it was super intense. And the feedback that my agent got was like Jenna blew us away. We absolutely loved it. Her scene was she just did a great job. We're going to pass on her because we just unfortunately don't think she's hot enough. Oh. That was my feedback.
我必须试镜的场景是这个非常情绪化、戏剧性的场景，我在哭，我想，关于我的母亲。这非常激烈。我的经纪人得到的反馈是，珍娜让我们大吃一惊。我们绝对喜欢它。她的场景是她做得很好。我们要放弃她，因为我们不幸地认为她不够性感。哦。那是我的反馈。
That was my feedback. You know, I have long fantasized that you and I would have a TV show where we were mom detectives. We've talked about this. What? We've never talked about this. Yes, we have where we would, like, drive around and solve just very, very small crime. Oh, yeah. We spent a few years, lady, but there was one night, there was one night.
那是我的反馈。你知道，我一直幻想你和我会有个电视节目，我们是妈妈侦探。我们谈过这个。什么？我们从来没谈过这个。是的，我们谈过，我们会，比如，开车到处解决非常、非常小的犯罪。哦，是的。我们花了几年的时间，女士，但有一个晚上，有一个晚上。
There might have been wine involved, but you and I had a few glasses of wine, and we were like, here's a great TV show, two moms solving very, very minor crimes. Like lost pets and, like, is someone cheating on someone? Yes. And remember, I think what sparked the whole thing is I. got a flyer on my door that a house a few doors down was having massages in the garage if you would like a massage and this sent my whole street into a tizzy we were like oh my god you were like is this erotic massage yes like who advertises massage in my garage there's got to be something fishy here and i was telling you this story did you investigate oh i did a few drivebys i did a few and
可能涉及葡萄酒，但你和我喝了几杯酒，我们就像，这是一个很棒的电视节目，两个妈妈解决非常、非常小的犯罪。比如丢失的宠物，比如，有人在欺骗某人吗？是的。还记得，我想引发这一切的是我。在我的门上收到一张传单，说几扇门外的一所房子如果想要按摩的话，可以在车库里按摩，这让我的整条街都陷入了混乱，我们就像，哦，天哪，你就像，这是色情按摩吗？是的，就像谁在我的车库里做按摩广告，肯定有什么猫腻，我正在告诉你这个故事，你调查了吗？哦，我做了几次开车经过，我做了几次，而且
and were they on the up and up the garage was never open, okay? I don't know whatever happened, but I took a few long walks past that house. Lady, you've seen the Americans. You need to dress up in a costume and go get a dang massage in that garage. That's how you're going to find out what's going on in there. I need to put on my wig and go for a massage. But me telling you that story, you and I decided mom detectives solving crimes no one cares about.
它们是正当的吗？车库从来没开过，好吗？我不知道发生了什么，但我几次长途走过那所房子。女士，你看过《美国谍梦》。你需要穿上戏服，去那个车库做个该死的按摩。那就是你发现里面发生了什么的方法。我需要戴上我的假发去按摩。但我告诉你那个故事，你和我决定了妈妈侦探解决没人关心的犯罪。
I once had a masseuse kind of offer me a happy ending and a massage. What? Was it a man or woman? It was a man. Where were you? I was. How did it come up? What did they say?
我曾经有一个按摩师在按摩时给了我一个“快乐结局”。什么？是男人还是女人？是个男人。你在哪儿？我在。它是怎么提出来的？他们说了什么？
I need to know everything. It was this one place that I would go to in Studio City. You know it all the time. Studio City is like the suburbs. This is where we moved in like year 10. of living in Los Angeles. We moved out to the suburbs. And I went to this place all the time.
我需要知道一切。就是我在工作室城去的那一个地方。你一直都知道。工作室城就像郊区。这是我们在洛杉矶生活了10年后搬到的地方。我们搬到了郊区。我一直去这个地方。
And I always had this female masseuse. And I was very loyal to this business. It's not in business anymore. Shocker. I'm not saying this is why. Did they move to the garage at the end of my street? They maybe did. They maybe did.
我一直有这个女按摩师。我对这家企业非常忠诚。它现在不在营业了。震惊。我不是说这就是原因。他们搬到我街尽头的车库了吗？他们可能搬了。他们可能搬了。
So I, you know, I went in and they didn't have my usual gal. And they offered me this, I'm not going to lie. Just this. Just a gorgeous man. What? I was a little bit like, do I get a massage from this hot guy? Do I, it feels interesting. This is a very personal question.
所以我，你知道，我进去了，他们没有我通常的那个女孩。他们给了我这个，我不撒谎。只是这个。只是一个华丽的男人。什么？我有点像，我从这个性感家伙那里得到按摩吗？我，它感觉很有趣。这是一个非常私人的问题。
Do you go full commando or do you leave your undies on when you get a massage? I take it all off. I can't. I can't. You wear your underwear during massages? I use my underwear. I've also been known to wear my socks because my feet get cold. Oh, I do wear my socks because my feet get cold.
你按摩时是全裸还是穿着内衣？我全脱了。我不能。我不能。你按摩时穿内衣？我用我的内衣。我也以穿袜子而闻名，因为我的脚很冷。哦，我确实穿袜子，因为我的脚很冷。
Oh, I do wear my socks because my feet get cold. And I never ever take off my underwear because I'm like, I don't know who's been on that table. I don't know. They changed the sheets. I don't care. I'm leaving my underwear on. There was just this like moment where it was near the end. And it was just like, what did he say?
哦，我确实穿袜子，因为我的脚很冷。而且我从来不脱内衣，因为我像，我不知道谁在那张桌子上。我不知道。他们换了床单。我不在乎。我要穿着内衣。就在快结束的时候，有那么一刻。就像，他说了什么？
Well, it was more like what he said with his hands, you know? What? What do you mean what he said with his hands? Where were his hands? They were just, you know, finishing up the massage. On your forehead, don't they normally finish the massage? Like, here's what it was. Tell me, am I misinterpreting?
好吧，更像是他用手说了什么，你知道？什么？你说的用手说了什么是什么意思？他的手在哪儿？他们只是，你知道，按摩快结束了。在你的前额，他们通常不是这样结束按摩的吗？就像，这就是它。告诉我，我误解了吗？
Am I misinterpreting? Because the whole time during this one particular massage, I just kept thinking I'm getting massage by a super hot. Oh, no. Were you projecting? Was I projecting? He just, his hands were on my legs, but they were on my thighs. And he was just like, are you good? And I was like, huh?
我误解了吗？因为在这次特别按摩的整个过程中，我一直以为我被一个超级性感的人按摩。哦，不。你在投射吗？我在投射吗？他只是，他的手在我的腿上，但它们在大腿上。他就像，你还好吗？我就像，嗯？
Yeah, I'm good. And then he moved up to my head and finished the massage. Did he say drop de corsage? Can I have the right of the thigh? I felt like I was in Happy Ending territory. I felt like I was in a world where if I gestured toward Happy Ending Lane, I think he might have gone down it with me, perhaps. I don't even know where we go from there, lady.
是的，我很好。然后他移到我的头上，结束了按摩。他说“脱掉胸衣”了吗？我可以有大腿的权利吗？我觉得我处于“快乐结局”领域。我觉得我处于一个如果我向“快乐结局”车道示意，我想他可能会和我一起走下去，也许。我甚至不知道我们从那里去哪儿，女士。
Where are we? where we are, Angela, is that Ben Franklin is telling all the women about his life, the history of his life. Yes, he's telling a story. It was a dark evening, you know. Oh, and you're hanging on every word. I'm hanging on every word, and I have to share with you. This is a very actory moment. I decided to do this. No one told me that I made the choice that Angela Martin would literally be enthralled by this man. And so when Randall Einhorn was directing, he had Matt Sown, the camera operator, like, pan across all of our expressions. And I had this expression of like, you know? Oh, and you're loving it. I'm loving it.
我们在哪儿？我们在哪儿，安吉拉，是本·富兰克林正在告诉所有女性关于他的生活，他生活的历史。是的，他正在讲一个故事。那是一个黑暗的夜晚，你知道。哦，你对每一个字都着迷。我对每一个字都着迷，我必须和你分享。这是一个非常“演员”的时刻。我决定这样做。没有人告诉我，我做出了安吉拉·马丁会字面意义上被这个人迷住的选择。所以当兰德尔·艾因霍恩执导时，他让摄像师马特·索恩，比如，扫过我们所有的表情。我有了那种表情，比如，你知道？哦，你很喜欢它。我很喜欢它。
And Randall was like, Angela, that is so great. Can you do that every time? And I was like, oh, yeah, oh, yeah. So that's my little actory choice, little nugget for you that I just thought that Angela Martin would be enthralled. Well, we had a very actory question for Andy Daley about this scene because we wanted to know if he did any research on the character of Ben Franklin in order to play this role. And here's what he had to say. I did prepare a bit. So as a office viewer, it always looked to me like the show was somewhat improvised.
兰德尔说，安吉拉，那太棒了。你能每次都那样做吗？我当时想，哦，是的，哦，是的。所以这就是我给你的小“演员”选择，小片段，我只是认为安吉拉·马丁会被迷住。好吧，我们对安迪·戴利关于这场戏有一个非常“演员”的问题，因为我们想知道他是否为了扮演这个角色对本·富兰克林这个角色做了任何研究。这就是他要说的。我确实准备了一点。所以作为一个办公室观众，它总是看起来像节目是即兴创作的。
I think it turns out, actually, that it's just really well written and really well acted and not really so much improvised. Of course, there is some improvising on the set, but I, not as much as I think I thought. It looks so spontaneous on television. But anyway, the point is that because I figured I would be improvising as a guy who impersonates Ben Franklin for a living, I figured I better know quite a bit about Ben Franklin. And so I just read Wikipedia, but I mean, I read it and I took notes and I kind of, you know, I read it a few times to trying to have. a lot of these biographical information in my mind.
我想事实证明，其实，它只是写得很好，演得很好，并不是那么即兴。当然，片场有一些即兴创作，但我，没有我想象的那么多。它在电视上看起来如此自发。但总之，重点是，因为我想我会作为一个以模仿本·富兰克林为生的人进行即兴创作，我想我最好对本·富兰克林了解很多。所以我只是读了维基百科，但我的意思是，我读了它，我做了笔记，我有点，你知道，我读了几次，试图拥有。很多这些传记信息在我的脑海里。
And as I will address any later answer to a later question, it came in handy. But that is the preparation that I did. I would do that. We would go around about it differently, but we'd show up with information. What does that mean? Go around about it differently? Well, it's just kind of like our research process. You know, you always like, you look at my notes and you're like, oh, God, your notes make me like queasy.
正如我稍后会回答后续问题一样，它派上了用场。但这就是我所做的准备。我会那样做。我们会以不同的方式绕过它，但我们会带着信息出现。那是什么意思？以不同的方式绕过它？好吧，这只是有点像我们的研究过程。你知道，你总是喜欢，你看我的笔记，你就像，哦，天哪，你的笔记让我觉得恶心。
have like a gazillion post-it notes and note cards and you have like a very like outline oh yes yeah i see what you're saying i would research ben franklin write an essay on it and bring it with me you would fill your script with 72 post-it notes filled with bits of information about ben franklin yes look and there it is there it is i mean the proof is right there you just held up your notes for this episode and it's like 72 post-it notes all around with arrows and highlighting well so listen, lady, before we get to Michael's man meet, should we take a break and then we'll come back and talk all about it? That's the segue of the month. It's definitely the segue for this episode.
有像一万亿个便利贴和笔记卡，你有一个非常像大纲，哦，是的，是的，我明白你的意思，我会研究本·富兰克林，写一篇关于它的文章，并随身携带，你会用72个写满本·富兰克林信息的便利贴填满你的剧本，是的，看，就在那里，就在那里，我的意思是证据就在那里，你刚才举起了你这一集的笔记，它就像72个便利贴，到处都是箭头和高亮，好吧，所以听着，女士，在我们进入迈克尔的“男人肉”之前，我们应该休息一下，然后回来谈谈这一切吗？这是本月的过渡。这绝对是这一集的过渡。
We'll be back in a second. Okay, guys, we are back. We are back. Michael is grilling steaks on his George Foreman grill. down in the warehouse, and Ryan asked him, is it the same grill that he used to grill his foot? And he's like, no. Okay, yes. But I got all the foot off. Incredible. Then we go upstairs and, whoa, Ben Franklin is tying a cherry stem with his tongue. And Pam asked him what kind of undergarments he's wearing. I just want to point out that Rashida's response as Karen to Ben Franklin tying that cherry stem. Tim is so perfect because she's like, Ben Franklin did not just hit Jerry Stim into a knot. It's so good.
我们一会儿回来。好的，伙计们，我们回来了。我们回来了。迈克尔正在他的乔治·福尔曼烤架上烤牛排。在仓库里，瑞恩问他，这是他用来烤脚的同一个烤架吗？他说，不。好吧，是的。但我把脚上的肉都弄掉了。不可思议。然后我们上楼，哇，本·富兰克林正在用舌头打樱桃梗。帕姆问他穿的是什么内衣。我只是想指出，拉什达作为凯伦对本·富兰克林打那个樱桃梗的反应。蒂姆太完美了，因为她说，本·富兰克林没有把樱桃梗打成结。太棒了。
And then, yeah, Pam, when you ask him that, he has one of my favorite lines. Andy is so good with this line. He's like, you're very saucy. Well, guys, we got a lot of fan questions about this scene. Aaron, Brooke, Olivia, Laura, and Marie all wrote in to say, did Ben Franklin actually tie the cherry stem with his mouth. And here is what Andy Daly had to say. Absolutely not.
然后，是的，帕姆，当你问他那个问题时，他有我最喜欢的台词之一。安迪这句台词说得太好了。他说，你很时髦。好吧，伙计们，我们收到了很多关于这场戏的粉丝问题。亚伦、布鲁克、奥利维亚、劳拉和玛丽都写信说，本·富兰克林真的用嘴打樱桃梗了吗？这就是安迪·戴利要说的。绝对没有。
That is not something I've even ever tried to do. That's crazy. But I am struggling to remember how we shot it. I guess I must have sort of stuck the tied cherry stem. It sort of in the core, stashed it in the corner of my mouth, you know, and then put the other one in and just kind of mimed it and then spit out. But listen, that's hard, too, to have a tied cherry stem hidden in your mouth and then put a real cherry stem in there that's not tied and then make sure you pull out the right one. I mean, that's pretty impressive right there.
那甚至不是我尝试过的事情。太疯狂了。但我正在努力回忆我们是怎么拍摄的。我想我一定把打结的樱桃梗粘住了。它有点在核心，藏在我的嘴里，你知道，然后把另一个放进去，只是模仿它，然后吐出来。但听着，那也很难，嘴里藏着一个打结的樱桃梗，然后放一个没打结的真樱桃梗进去，然后确保你拉出正确的一个。我的意思是，那真的很令人印象深刻。
But I might be remembering it wrong. It may actually be that the camera kind of swung off me long enough to not have to be so sneaky about it. I don't remember. But the short answer to your question is, no, I did not really tie that cherry stem with my tongue. I can't imagine how one does that or why one would take the time and effort to learn how. I mean, I know why people do that. Is it like a look what my tongue can do kind of thing? Yeah.
但我可能记错了。可能实际上是摄像机从我身上移开的时间足够长，不需要那么鬼鬼祟祟。我不记得了。但你问题的简短回答是，不，我并没有真的用舌头打那个樱桃梗。我无法想象一个人怎么做，或者为什么要花时间和精力去学习如何做。我的意思是，我知道人们为什么那样做。这就像“看我的舌头能做什么”那种事情吗？是的。
It's a display of your tongue agility. It's like a sexual thing. Why did you say it was such authority? Hey, I know. I know why people do that. Well, people want to know if either of us can tie a cherry stem with our mouths. It's a little bit of an inappropriate. question. I mean, it's personal. Can you, Jenna? You know what? Here's, you know what I'm
这是你舌头敏捷性的展示。这就像一种性行为。你为什么说得那么有权威？嘿，我知道。我知道人们为什么那样做。好吧，人们想知道我们俩是否能用嘴打樱桃梗。这有点不合适。问题。我的意思是，这是私人的。你能吗，珍娜？你知道吗？这是，你知道我在
going to say? I know if I can. I know the answer to that question. Wait, people are rodent asking if you and I can tie a cherry stem into a knot? Yes, it's a very, very personal question. Is it? It's very personal. Like, who cares? Who cares if you can tie one or not? Like, seriously? What does that mean? Really? Come on. Well, where did this start? I feel like this started in like a movie from the 80s or something. Does anybody know? I feel like this took off.
要说什么？我知道我能不能。我知道那个问题的答案。等等，人们在问你和我能不能把樱桃梗打成结？是的，这是一个非常、非常私人的问题。是吗？非常私人。就像，谁在乎？谁在乎你能不能打一个？就像，说真的？那是什么意思？真的？得了吧。好吧，这是从哪儿开始的？我觉得这是从80年代的电影之类的开始的。有人知道吗？我觉得这火了。
I remember this from my youth. It was like this whole like thing. Can you tie a cherry stem in your mouth? I mean, so we weren't we all doing it? Weren't we all tying cherry stems with our mouth? We all tried. Can this generation's youth tie cherry stems in their mouth? We'll never know.
我记得我年轻时有这个。就像整个事情。你能用嘴打樱桃梗吗？我的意思是，所以我们不是都在做吗？我们不是都在用嘴打樱桃梗吗？我们都试过。这一代的年轻人能用嘴打樱桃梗吗？我们永远不会知道。
You know what? Go on TikTok or something. They're probably doing it on the talk. Is that what they call it? On the talk? Get on the talk. I'm sure they don't. Now, Ben Franklin, winks at Pam.
你知道吗？去TikTok之类的。他们可能在“谈话”上做。那是他们叫它的吗？在“谈话”上？去“谈话”上。我敢肯定他们没有。现在，本·富兰克林，向帕姆眨眼。
Hey, sassy, wink. Jenna, I have a question for you. What is it? Is an unsolicited wink ever a good thing? Or is it always a dushy thing? Mm. It's a douche move. I think it's a little dushy.
嘿，时髦，眨眼。珍娜，我有个问题问你。是什么？未经请求的眨眼是一件好事吗？还是总是一件混蛋的事情？嗯。这是混蛋行为。我觉得有点混蛋。
I think, like, I mean, A, who even does it? Who's like, who's like, hey, huh? Yeah. Well, it's interesting because we had someone right in. Devin Crutchley said, did Pam secretly have a real crush on Ben Franklin because she seemed to be playing into the banter even after he becomes overly flirty with her? And others start picking up on it and playing along. here's the thing guys I was so utterly charmed by literally everything Andy Daly was doing as
我觉得，我的意思是，A，谁会那样做？谁会像，谁会像，嘿，嗯？是的。好吧，这很有趣，因为我们有人写信来。德文·克拉奇利说，帕姆是否暗中对本·富兰克林有真正的好感，因为即使在他变得过度调情后，她似乎也在配合这种玩笑？其他人开始注意到它并跟着玩。这就是事情，伙计们，我被安迪·戴利作为
Ben Franklin that I am only ever like smiling at him it had to have been coming through in my performance and so I think that might have given you the impression that Pam secretly had a crush on Ben Franklin because I personally had a crush on Andy Daley's performance well I did not see it that way at all I just I just saw it as like listen, none of us are having to work. We're in this room together. We're drinking champagne.
本·富兰克林所做的一切彻底迷住了，以至于我只是对他微笑，它一定是在我的表演中表现出来了，所以我认为这可能给了你帕姆暗中对本·富兰克林有好感的印象，因为我个人对安迪·戴利的表演有好感。好吧，我一点也没那样看。我只是，我只是把它看作，听着，我们都不用工作。我们在这个房间里在一起。我们在喝香槟。
We're just like having a good time. So, you know, that's how I saw it. I mean, I didn't want Ben Franklin to leave. So, you know, I was going to egg him on. Yeah. That was, I think, Pam's, where Pam's coming from. Keep him talking. The longer he's talking, the last time I'm sitting there answering phones, looking at the back of Jim's head.
我们只是在玩得开心。所以，你知道，这就是我看到的。我的意思是，我不想让本·富兰克林离开。所以，你知道，我要怂恿他。是的。我想这就是帕姆的想法。让他继续说。他说的越久，我坐在那里接电话、看着吉姆后脑勺的时间就越少。
Wait, I just have to say, while this wink is happening in the conference room, In the warehouse, Michael has been grilling steaks, they're done. And he's like, hey, guys, who wants some man meat? And Dwight goes, I know. I want some man meat. And then Creed picks the steak up with his hands because Stanley tries to cut it with a plastic fork and it breaks, which made me laugh so hard. And then Creed just picks it up and starts eating it. We should have texted Creed to ask him how that steak tasted.
等等，我必须说，当这个眨眼在会议室发生时，在仓库里，迈克尔一直在烤牛排，它们做好了。他说，嘿，伙计们，谁想要一些“男人肉”？德怀特说，我知道。我想要一些“男人肉”。然后克里德用手拿起牛排，因为斯坦利试图用塑料叉子切它，它断了，这让我笑得太厉害了。然后克里德只是拿起它开始吃。我们应该给克里德发短信问他那块牛排味道如何。
Oh, we should have. I have to tell you guys, you know, Creed lives down my street, right? He's at the end of my street. And he stopped by the other night And he said to us, guys, you have got to watch this show alone Where they drop people off in the Arctic And then they have to survive. It's like a survivalist show.
哦，我们应该的。我必须告诉你们，伙计们，你知道，克里德住在我那条街上，对吧？他在我那条街的尽头。他那天晚上顺便过来，他对我们说，伙计们，你们一定要看这个节目《Alone》，他们把人扔在北极，然后他们必须生存。这就像一个生存主义者节目。
Jenna, I thought of you. What one man can do or whatever? Another one can. You know. No, don't whatever. Don't whatever. One of the greatest lines written by one of the great American playwrights, David Mamet, whatever.
珍娜，我想到你了。一个人能做什么或者什么的？另一个人也能。你知道。不，不要什么。不要什么。由伟大的美国剧作家之一大卫·马梅特写的最伟大的台词之一，什么。
what one man has done another can do okay well let me tell you jenna you've got to watch this show it's so so freaking good creed has got us in it we are so invested it's the most intense survival series on television and it's in the arctic i'm fascinated it's so good it's called alone do they have supplies they get to bring a few things but they have to pick and choose and so like oh like One guy, you could bring a fire starter thing, but one guy decided not to because he was like, I can make my own fire. But then the first day, he was like spent all day trying to make fire. And he was like, damn it, I should have brought that thing. But anyway, when I saw Creed, who had just told me about this survivalist show, grabbed the steak with two hands and gnaw on it.
所谓“别人能做到的，我也能做到”。好吧，让我告诉你，珍娜，你一定要看这个节目，它真的太棒了。克里德也看了，我们都沉迷其中。这是电视上最紧张刺激的生存类节目，而且是在北极拍摄的。我太着迷了，真的很好看，节目叫《荒野独居》。他们有补给吗？他们可以带几样东西，但必须精挑细选。比如，有个人本可以带个生火工具，但他没带，因为他觉得“我自己能生火”。结果第一天，他花了一整天时间试图生火。他当时就想：“该死，我真该带上那个东西。”总之，当我看到克里德——他刚跟我推荐了这个生存节目——用双手抓起牛排大口啃的时候。
Yeah. It has made me think of. It all came full circle in your brain. And you need to see it. You love survivalist stuff. I do. Okay. Now we have to get into the very, very awkward scene that is Karen and Pam, ooh, in the kitchen.
是啊。这让我想到了……你脑子里的一切都串联起来了。你一定要看。你喜欢生存类节目。我是喜欢。好了，现在我们得聊聊凯伦和帕姆在厨房里那场非常、非常尴尬的戏了。
They're kind of joking about Ben Franklin. I feel like they're both like doing a bit about how did he become a Ben Franklin impersonator. And all of a sudden, Karen takes a sharp left turn and she says, hey, you know, I just want you to know, Jim told me, you know, that you guys kissed. and, you know, and Pam's like, what the what? She is, she's like, what is happening right now? It's like her computer shut down. Yes. Now, pretty much none of what she says after this makes any sense.
她们当时在开关于本杰明·富兰克林的玩笑。我觉得她们俩都在演，讨论他是怎么成为本杰明·富兰克林模仿者的。突然，凯伦话锋一转，她说：“嘿，你知道吗，我只是想让你知道，吉姆告诉我了，你们俩接过吻。”然后，帕姆就一脸懵。她当时心想：什么鬼？她就像是电脑死机了一样。没错。在那之后，她说的几乎没一句是正常的。
No, and, okay, so we had someone right in. Jackie Cortez said when Pam answers, oh, yeah, to Karen, when Karen asked if she still has feelings for Jim, do you think that was because? Pam was feeling brave in the moment, but that she was like trying to say her real feelings in that moment, and then she backs out when she sees Karen's face and also how much of this was scripted and how much of it was improvised. Okay, so first of all, this scene plays out exactly as it was scripted. All of those like awkward jumps in dialogue were all scripted. I just think it is such a great piece of writing. And I remember, I felt being challenged as an actor to make
不，而且，我们有位听众来信了。杰基·科尔特斯说，当凯伦问帕姆是否还对吉姆有感觉时，帕姆回答“哦，是啊”，你觉得这是因为帕姆当时觉得很勇敢，想在那一刻说出真心话，然后看到凯伦的表情后又退缩了吗？还有，这场戏有多少是剧本写的，有多少是即兴发挥的？好吧，首先，这场戏完全是按照剧本演的。所有那些对话中尴尬的跳跃都是剧本写好的。我真的觉得这是一段非常棒的剧本。我记得当时作为演员，我感到很有挑战性，要表现出
all those different turns that Pam has to make in the scene. And so when she says, oh, yeah, that's because she heard the question, you don't have feelings for Jim, right? And she's like, oh, yeah, I don't have feelings. But that's not what Karen said. Karen said, do you still have feelings for Jim? And she's like, oh, yeah. But like, Pam is just like, She's not hearing everything, and she's just like her mind is being blown right now by the fact that Jim told Karen this. Yeah. And you know what? Because now it's everything we were talking about.
帕姆在戏里必须经历的所有那些情绪转折。所以当她说“哦，是啊”时，那是因为她听到的问题是“你对吉姆没感觉了，对吧？”，于是她说“哦，是啊，我没感觉”。但凯伦问的并不是那个，凯伦问的是“你还对吉姆有感觉吗？”，而她回答“哦，是啊”。帕姆当时根本没听全，她整个人都被吉姆告诉凯伦这件事给震惊了。是啊。而且你知道吗？因为现在这不再是什么秘密了。这不再是吉姆和帕姆的秘密了。我认为这告诉帕姆，他正在认真对待与凯伦的关系，因为他愿意告诉她真相。现在我觉得帕姆就像是被车灯照住的鹿一样，完全呆住了。嗯，我觉得这太精彩了。我觉得你们俩演得太棒了。剧本写得好，演得也好。而且，哦，这让我感到太尴尬了。
It's not a secret anymore. It's not Jim and Pam's secret anymore. That, I think, tells Pam that he's taking this relationship with Karen seriously because he's willing to tell her the real truth. And now I think Pam is just in like a Darren headlights kind of mode. Well, I thought it was fantastic. I thought the two of you did such a great job with it. It was written so well and acted so well. And, oh, it made me so uncomfortable.
所以你们知道你们做到了，你们完成了任务。拉希达和我拍那场戏时玩得很开心。好了，我们要回到仓库吗？凯文正在那里带着大家玩牌。是的，他说这是“无上限二至七低牌”，我想这和他在“赌场之夜”玩的是同一种，对吧？是的，他在“赌场之夜”告诉我们，他在世界扑克大赛里赢的就是这个。然后迈克尔像个彻头彻尾的白痴一样洗牌。是的。是的，我们有一位粉丝凯蒂捕捉到了一个细节，她说在这一集大约12分46秒的时候，凯文又戴上眼镜了。
So you guys know you did the right, you did your job. Rashid and I had a lot of fun shooting that scene. All right, should we go back down to the warehouse where Kevin is leading all of the guys in a card game? Yeah, he says it's a no limit deuce to seven lowball, which I think is the same one he did in Casino Night, right? Yes, that is what he won in the World Series of Poker, he tells us, in Casino Night. And then Michael shuffles the cards like a total idiot. Yes. Yes, we had a fan catch from Katie, who said in this episode around 12 minutes, 46 seconds, Kevin's wearing glasses again.
他就在那儿。他玩扑克时戴眼镜，但工作时不戴。不是作为会计工作时，只是玩牌时才戴。这时伊丽莎白进来了。她从达里尔的办公室走出来。她脱掉了运动裤和运动衫，现在穿的是一套性感的办公室撕拉式服装。我们收到克里斯汀·特罗吉尔发来的一个重大粉丝发现。克里斯汀，你发现了什么？
There he is. He wears glasses when he plays poker, but not when he's working. Not as an accountant, just when he plays cards. And this is when Elizabeth enters. She comes out of Daryl's office. She has changed out of her sweatpants and sweatshirt, and she is now in a breakaway, sexy office attire. We had a huge fan catch from Kristen Trowgill. Kristen, what'd you catch?
帕姆在“邓迪奖”颁奖礼上穿的那件衬衫，和脱衣舞娘伊丽莎白在“本杰明·富兰克林”那一集里撕掉的是同一件。天哪。他们回收了你的一件衬衫吗？是服装组把它改成了那种撕拉式的吗？是的。是的，伊丽莎白穿的是我以前的一件衬衫。其实我第一次穿它是在打篮球的时候。
Pam's shirt in the Dundies is the same shirt that Elizabeth the stripper rips off in Ben Franklin. Oh, my God. Did they recycle one of your shirts? Did wardrobe make it like a breakaway kind of blouse or something? Yes. Yes. Elizabeth is wearing one of my old shirts. So I actually first wore it for basketball.
然后我在“邓迪奖”上又穿了一次。我联系了我们的服装主管嘉莉·贝内特，问了这件事。她怎么说？她说剧本里没写这个。这不是她接到的任何指令。因为很多人写信来问，这是故意的吗？你们是想让我们注意到这是帕姆穿过的那件一模一样的衬衫吗？这是剧本里写的笑话吗？并不是。她说通常当客串演员在最后一刻才定下来时，她没时间去为他们购物。所以服装设计师会去他们的所谓“退役服装库”。这是一堆已经退役、但曾经属于主要演员的服装。所以她必须找到一件适合伊丽莎白穿的衬衫，然后还得把它改成
And then I wear it again in Dundies. And I reached out to Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe supervisor, about this. What'd she say? She said that this was not in the script. This was not like any kind of direction she was given. because a lot of people did write in and ask, like, was this on purpose? Did you want us to notice that this was the identical shirt that Pam has worn? Was that a joke that was written in the script? It wasn't. She said that oftentimes when a guest actor is cast at the very last minute, she doesn't have time to go shopping for them. So what wardrobe designers do is they go into their quote unquote retired wardrobe. And this is a stash of out for, that have been retired, but that used to belong to the main cast members. So she had to find a shirt that fit Elizabeth and then it had to be converted into a
撕拉式衬衫。他们实在没时间去购物并把衬衫改成撕拉式的，因为杰基定下来的时间太紧了，他们只能去翻帕姆的旧衣服。他们就是这么做的。她说她真不敢相信有人注意到了。好吧，听着，脱衣舞娘伊丽莎白，你真幸运，没穿到安吉拉·马丁的退役服装。哦，不。哦，不。那可就太糟糕了。那会非常糟糕。不过这真是个了不起的发现。我知道。嘉莉还说这种事在电视剧里经常发生。她说你经常会发现主要演员的退役服装被重新利用给客串演员。我觉得每个人都可以留意一下，还有那个假包。
ripaway shirt. And so they just didn't have time to go shopping and convert a shirt into a ripaway shirt because the timing of when Jackie was cast, they had to just go into Pam's old wardrobe. And that's what they did. And she said she can't believe that people noticed. Well, listen, Elizabeth, the stripper, you're lucky you didn't get any of Angela Martin's retired wardrobe. Oh, no. Oh, no. That would have been very bad. It would have been very bad. That's a great catch, though. I know. And Carrie also said that this happens all the time on TV shows. She said you will often spot retired clothing from the main cast being repurposed for guest actors. I feel like everybody, you can look for that along with the fake you.
好了，现在她开始跳舞了。音乐是Bad Company的《Feel Like Makin' Love》。没人想要这场舞。鲍勃·万斯不想要。迈克尔心想：好吧。这太尴尬了。他不知道该怎么办。他感到非常不自在。他只是开始嘟囔：“你闻起来像汰渍洗衣粉。”没错，闻起来像汰渍。你用汰渍吗？有几个人写信来问。佐伊和丹问，当伊丽莎白在迈克尔身上跳舞时，有多少对话是剧本写的。全部都是。你们知道，我们聊过一些关于有人必须扇别人耳光的戏，我们是怎么请特技协调员的。你在这种戏里也会做同样的事。任何有触碰、贴身热舞、性爱场面的戏，它们都是
bag. Well, now she starts her dance. It's to bad companies, feel like making love. No one wanted the dance. Bob Vance didn't want it. Michael's like, okay. And this is so awkward. He doesn't know what to do with himself. He's so uncomfortable. He just starts muttering, you smell like Tide. Yep, smell like Tide. Do you use Tide? We had a couple of people write in. Zouye and Dan asked when Elizabeth is dancing on Michael, how much of the dialogue was scripted. All of it. And you guys, we've talked a little bit about like scenes where someone has to slap someone, you know, and how we bring in a stunt coordinator. You do that kind of stuff in scenes like this, too. Any scenes that have any kind of like touching, dancing up on someone, a sex scene, they are
编排好的。你不能自由发挥。是的，这和打斗戏没什么两样。就像是：坐在这儿。我要把胳膊放在这儿。然后我要站在这儿。一切都是排练好的。你不会即兴发挥这些东西。是的。所以她坐在他腿上的位置，她要跳的所有舞步，她什么时候撕开衬衫，都是剧本写好的。对话也是剧本写的。当我回去看剧本时，我并不惊讶，因为我想，在这样的时刻，他们是不可能即兴发挥的。不，那全是剧本写的。迈克尔当时完全不知所措。他心想：这不对。我有女朋友。
choreographed. You do not free. Yeah, it's really no different than like a fight scene. It's like, sit here. I'm going to put my arm here. Then I'm going to stand here. It's all rehearsed. You don't freestyle this stuff. Yeah. So where she sits on his leg, all of the dancing she's going to do, when she's going to rip open her shirt, very scripted. The dialogue was scripted. I wasn't surprised when I went back to the script because I thought, yeah, I don't think in a moment like this that they would have freestyled that. No, that was all scripted. And Michael is just overwhelmed. He's like, this is wrong. I have a girlfriend.
然后他冲了出去。对他来说这一切太多了。而且德怀特，作为一个节俭的人，心想：嘿，我付了你三个小时的钱。我要让你工作满三个小时。所以现在你得去接电话。而且因为奥斯卡不见踪影，尽管他已经回来了。珍娜，我们是乱序拍摄的吗？为什么奥斯卡不在那儿？
And he storms off. It was just all too much for him. And quite, being the frugal fella he is, is like, hey, I paid you for three hours. I'm going to get three hours of work out of you. So now you have to go answer phones. And because Oscar is nowhere to be seen, even though he has returned. Did we shoot this out of order, Jenna? Why isn't Oscar there?
我不知道，因为《旅行推销员》和《回归》是在十月拍摄的。是的。而这一集是在一月拍摄的。所以奥斯卡不在那儿确实说不通。确实。总之，德怀特带伊丽莎白去会计部坐在奥斯卡的位子上。伊丽莎白对安吉拉来说太有压迫感了。她就像是……那种非常伊丽莎白式的，像是在扇风。
I don't know because the traveling salesman and the return were shot in October. Yeah. And this was shot in January. So it doesn't make sense why Oscar isn't there. It doesn't. So anyway, Dwight brings Elizabeth to accounting to sit in Oscar's seat. Elizabeth is very overwhelming for Angela. And she's like, ha, ha, like sort of like this very Elizabethan, like, fanning myself.
好吧，重点是。她夸奖了你的婴儿海报。没关系。没关系。我知道。她真的是。她和你角色一样是婴儿爵士乐的粉丝，但很多人写信来问。塞拉、蒂芙尼、
Well, here's the thing. She complements your baby poster. It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. I know. She really is. She's a. fan of baby jazz like your character is, but a lot of people wrote in. Sierra, Tiffany,
卡米尔和克里斯塔都问：那张婴儿海报怎么又挂上去了？安吉拉，是你的角色在奥斯卡休假时把它挂上去的吗？她们想知道这个。我喜欢这个理论。我完全支持。奥斯卡一走，她就想：我的海报要挂回去了。与此同时，本杰明·富兰克林，也就是戈登，正在接待处撩帕姆。他在音频片段里也提到了这一点。哦。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。现在迈克尔不知道该怎么办了。他觉得自己背叛了简。他去和本杰明·富兰克林谈话。想要本杰明·富兰克林的建议，本杰明·富兰克林也就是戈登，基本上说：“我觉得她不需要知道这些信息。”迈克尔心想：本杰明·富兰克林，你真是个卑鄙小人。伙计们，本杰明·富兰克林在对待女性方面确实是个卑鄙小人。他，他实际上真的是。如果你去查一下，他真的，他真的和很多女人睡过。不过这一集里有一件事是不准确的。
Camille, and Krista are like, what is the baby poster doing back up? Angela, did your character put it up when Oscar went on his sabbatical? That's what they want to know. I love this theory. I fully support it. The minute Oscar left, she's like, my poster is going back up. Meanwhile, Ben Franklin, a.k.a. Gordon, is hitting on Pam at reception. And he said a little bit about this in his audio clip. Oh. So funny. So funny. And now Michael doesn't know what to do. He feels like he's cheated on Jan. He talks to Ben Franklin. Once Ben Franklin's advice, Ben Franklin slash Gordon basically says, I don't think she needs to know this information. And Michael is like, Ben Franklin, you're kind of a sleaze bag. And you guys, Ben Franklin, Franklin was kind of size bag with women. He, like, actually really was. If you look it up, he just, he, like, literally slept with so many women. And there's one thing that's inaccurate in this episode, though.
在这一集里，你知道，他和一位不是他妻子的女人生了一个孩子。在这一集里，他说，她不知道他有……他有点对迈克尔说：“我生了一个孩子，但我从来没告诉过我妻子。”但那不是真的。实际上，他的妻子像对待自己的孩子一样抚养了那个孩子。天哪。他的妻子黛博拉是个圣人，我要说，她忍受了本的恶劣行为。好吧，现在迈克尔不喜欢本杰明·富兰克林的建议，所以他打算去问伊丽莎白的建议。
In this episode, you know, he had a child with one woman who was not his wife. And in the episode, he says that, like, she didn't know that he had. he sort of says to Michael, like, I fathered a child and I never told my wife about it. But that's not true. Actually, his wife raised that child like her own. Oh, my gosh. His wife, Deborah, was a saint, I'm going to say, and she put up with Ben's bad behavior. Well, now Michael did not like his advice from Ben Franklin, so he's going to go ask Elizabeth for her advice instead.
这是她给迈克尔的建议，引用如下：“秘密，秘密没乐趣。秘密，秘密会伤人。”安吉拉，你知道那是什么吗？我正想说，请告诉我你研究过这句台词。它是来自什么童书吗？它是出自哪里的？这是女子组合“No Secrets”演唱的歌曲《No Secrets》的开场歌词。来自她们的专辑。
Here is her advice to Michael, quote, Secrets, secrets are no fun. Secrets, secrets hurt someone. Angela, do you know what that is? I was about to say, please tell me you researched this quote. Is it from like a children's book? What is it from? These are the opening lyrics to a song called No Secrets by a girl band called No Secrets. from their album.
《No Secrets》？《No Secrets》。我让萨姆和科迪找了个片段。在这儿，安吉拉。秘密，秘密没乐趣。秘密，秘密会伤人。她们有个游戏。
No secrets? No secrets. And I asked Sam and Cody to pull a clip. Here it is, Angela. Secrets, secrets are no fun. Secret, secrets. Hurts someone. They had a game.
“No Secrets”是一个英美女子组合，很像辣妹组合。她们有一首热门单曲，是翻唱金·怀尔德的《Kids in America》。我们是美国的年轻人。哦，我们是美国的年轻人。你记得那首歌吗？我有点印象。她们随后又出了一首热门单曲《That's What Girls Do》，但她们只出过一张专辑。她们开始制作第二张，
No Secrets, was a British American girl band, very reminiscent of Spice Girls. They had one hit, which was a cover of Kids in America, that song by Kim Wild. We're the kids in America. Oh, we're the kids in America. Do you remember that song? I kind of do. They followed up with another hit single, That's What Girls Do, but they only ever made one album. They started on a second one.
但从未发行。乐队因为分歧解散了。其中一名成员声称是家长闹剧和干预导致的。但，重点是。敏迪·卡灵写了这一集。我毫不怀疑，我心里毫无疑问，她有“No Secrets”组合的《No Secrets》那张专辑。这就是她知道引用这句台词的原因。
but it was never released. The band broke up over disagreements. And one member claims it was parent drama and interference. But I, here's the thing. Mindy Kaling wrote this episode. I have no doubt, no doubt in my mind, that she has the album No Secrets by No Secrets. And that's how she knew to quote this line.
我的意思是，这看起来非常具体。我们在这一场戏里还收到了科琳娜·刘发来的粉丝发现，她说在17分52秒，迈克尔身后的冰箱上有一张“Silver on Spruce”的传单。科琳娜说：“我做了一点深入调查，看起来这是一家真实存在的企业，有两个不同的地址。传单上的电话号码也是对的。我查过了。”科琳娜是对的。
I mean, it seems pretty specific. We also had a fan catch in the scene from Corinna Liu, who says at 17 minutes, 52 seconds, There is a flyer on the refrigerator behind Michael for silver on spruce. Corina says, I did a small deep dive and it looks like this is a real business with two different addresses. And the telephone number on the flyer is correct. I checked it out. Corinna is right.
是的，“Silver on Spruce”。我不知道这家珠宝店有没有接到过恶作剧电话，因为你可以在我们这一集里看到电话号码。嗯，我想科琳娜不是第一个暂停画面看这个的人。我怀疑那些看《The Talk》的孩子们有没有打过那个电话。女士，那节目不叫《The Talk》。你没法让他们去打那个电话。好吧。
Yes, silver on spruce. I wonder if this jewelry store has gotten like prank calls because you can see the phone number in our episode. Well, I imagine Corinna is not the first person to freeze frame on this. I wonder if the kids on the top. have called the number. Lady, it is not called the talk. And you're not going to get them to call it the talk. Okay.
天哪，每个人都在谈论《The Talk》。好了。伙计们，我们快结束了。我保证。我保证。但我们不能在不讨论这场戏的情况下结束这一集，德怀特正在审问本杰明·富兰克林，因为吉姆说服了他，这就是穿越时空来拜访他的真正的本杰明·富兰克林。
Gosh, everyone on the talk. All right. Guys, we're almost done. I promise. I promise. But we cannot leave this episode without talking about this scene where Dwight is interrogating Ben Franklin because Jim has convinced him that this is the real Ben Franklin who has time traveled to visit him.
拜访我们在邓德·米夫林的办公室。他有99%的把握这不是真正的本杰明·富兰克林，但他还是要审问他。这场戏太搞笑了。太搞笑了。德怀特一直在用关于他生活年代的问题来挑战他。安迪告诉我们这是他最喜欢拍摄的戏份之一，他是这么说的。这就是我研究本杰明·富兰克林派上用场的地方。那场戏里有很多剧本写的台词，雷恩·威尔逊在挑战这个本杰明·富兰克林模仿者，试图让他出丑，找出他关于本杰明·富兰克林知识的漏洞。
visit us at Dunder Mifflin. He's 99% sure it's not the real Ben Franklin, but he's going to interrogate him anyway. The scene was so funny. So funny. And Dwight is just like challenging him with questions about the time period when he lived. And Andy told us that this was one of his favorite to shoot and this is what he had to say. This is where my research into Ben Franklin came in handy. There were a bunch of scripted lines in that scene where Rain Wilson is challenging this Ben Franklin impersonator, trying to trip him up to find the lapse in his knowledge about Ben Franklin.
所以他一直在抛出所有这些问题。但他即兴发挥的一个问题是：“你是近视还是远视？”那不在剧本里。事先从未讨论过他会说那句话。他只是在拍摄过程中随口说了出来。而我，因为我刚读过本杰明·富兰克林的维基百科页面，知道本杰明·富兰克林发明了双焦眼镜。他发明双焦眼镜是因为他需要它，因为他的远视力有问题，
And so it's just throwing all these questions. But one that he improvised was, are you near-sighted or far-sighted? That was not in the script. It was never discussed beforehand that he was going to say that. he just threw that out in the middle of a take. And I, because I had just read the Wikipedia page about Ben Franklin, knew that Ben Franklin invented the bifocals. And he invented the bifocals because he needed him because his distance site was challenged,
他的近视力也有问题。所以我能够不假思索、毫不犹豫地说：“两者都有，这就是我发明双焦眼镜的原因。”这是一种不同寻常的、神奇的即兴时刻。他问了我一个我正好准备了完美答案的问题，这太奇怪了。非常奇怪。事实上，当他们喊“卡”的时候，我记得敏迪·卡灵说：“你们事先商量好了吗？”我们俩都说：“没有。”我们都被难住了。这是一个即兴时刻，这太奇怪了。是的，它最终出现在了节目里，当然，为什么不呢？所以，是的，这就是我的回答。太棒了。女士，你知道，这是我书呆子时刻，我要说这就是集体
as was his reading site. And so I was able to say, without having to think about it or hesitate, both, that's why I invented the bifocal. And that is an unusual kind of magical, improvised moment. It's so strange that he asked me a question for which I was prepared with the perfect answer. It's very strange. And in fact, when they called Cut, I remember Mindy Kaling saying, did you guys work that out beforehand? And we were both like, no. And we were all kind of stumped. It's very strange that that's an improvised moment. And yeah, it ended up in the show, of course, because why wouldn't it? So, yes, that's my answer. Amazing. Lady, this is, you know, my nerdy moment where I say it's the group
意识。另外，演员们，这就是为什么你们需要做准备工作。永远，永远。伙计们，演员不会只是出现在片场然后随心所欲地演。我们学习。这是一门手艺。我们认真对待它。我总是，总是尝试去充实我的角色。如果他们给我任何一点线索，比如，显然他有本杰明·富兰克林。我会做深入研究。所以我脑子里有所有这些东西，以防我需要用到。女士，你觉得这就是我们为播客做所有这些深入研究的原因吗？是因为那是我们演员的大脑在工作吗？因为那是我会为一场戏做的事情。是的。而且，珍娜，这也稍微让我们窥见了一个事实，那就是我们在大学里可能就是那种
mind. Also, actors, this is why you need to do your prep work. Always, always. Guys, actors do not just show up on set and just make it up as they go. We study. It's a craft. We take it seriously. I always, always try to flesh out my character. And if they give it, me any kind of nugget like, you know, obviously he had Ben Franklin. I do a deep dive. So I have all this in my head in case I need it. Lady, do you think that's why we do all these deep dives for the podcast? Is it like, is that our actor brains at work? Because that's the kind of stuff I would do for a scene. Yeah. It's also, Jenna, a little bit of a glimpse into maybe the fact that we were kind of the dorks in college
泡在图书馆里的书呆子。在进入下一场戏之前，安吉拉，我有一个来自玛吉·唐纳的非常简短的粉丝发现。我称之为“寒冷的证据”。哦。你知道，我们聊过很多关于我们的片场一直很冷的事。
who hung out in the library. Before we move on to the next scene, Angela, I have a very quick fan catch from Maggie Donner. I'm calling it proof of cold. Oh. You know, we've talked a lot about how our set was really cold all the time.
在德怀特的谈话头背景里，当他在谈论本杰明·富兰克林时，你可以看到凯伦坐在她的办公桌前，腿上盖着一条毯子。哦，不会吧。玛吉·唐纳捕捉到了那个寒冷的证据。哦，玛吉，那真是有点冷。哦，玛吉。
In the background of Dwight's talking head where he's talking about Ben Franklin, you can see Karen sitting at her desk and she has a blanket on her lap. Oh, no way. Maggie Donner caught that proof of cold. Oh, Maggie, that's a little bit of cold. Oh, Maggie.
那真是个伟大的发现。哦，那是个好发现。是的，我们总是冻得要死。好吧，你知道，珍娜，我们不能在帕姆没有在休息室里有这个时刻的情况下结束，她当着吉姆的面告诉瑞安：“你知道吗？我准备好让你帮我介绍对象了。”是的。她是认真的。她说：“是的，我想和你的商学院朋友出去约会。”
That's such a great catch. Oh, that's a good one. Yeah, we were always freezing. Well, you know, Jenna, we can't wrap up without Pam having this moment in the break room where she tells Ryan in front of Jim, you know what? I'm ready for you to set me up. Yeah. She is. She's like, yeah, I want to go out with one of your business school friends.
那是怎么回事？她感觉到了。她和凯伦进行了那次谈话。艾伦现在知道了。吉姆告诉她了。吉姆说他们进行了所有这些非常长、非常真诚的谈话。帕姆心想：哦，该死，我最好也把自己推销出去。嗯，吉姆说：“哦，也许你应该和本杰明·富兰克林约会。”我觉得帕姆心想：你知道吗？你不需要告诉我我该和谁约会。好吧。只是坐回他身边，看着我现在的报复性约会吧。差不多。差不多。嗯，然后在我们走之前，安吉拉，我们必须讨论一个事实。迈克尔给简打电话，承认有一个女人在他身上跳舞。简说：“什么时候？这个周末？昨晚？这事是什么时候发生的？”他说：“不，是在工作时的仓库里。”
What's that about? She's feeling it. She's had this conversation where Karen. Aaron now knows. Jim has told her. Jim is saying they're having all these, like, really long, heartfelt talks. Pam's like, oh, crap, I might as well get myself out there. Well, and Jim's like, oh, maybe you should go out with Ben Franklin. And I think Pam's like, you know what? You need to don't tell me who I should date. Okay. Just sit back to him and watch me revenge date now. Pretty much. Pretty much. Well, and then before we go, Angela, we have to discuss the fact that. Michael calls Jan and confesses that he had a woman dancing up on him. And Jan's like, when? This weekend? Last night? Like, when did this happen? He's like, no, it was at work in the warehouse.
她说：“迈克尔，我……我简直……”他说：“我很抱歉，你生气了吗？”她说：“我……我快要解雇你了。”他说：“哦，真是如释重负。我有世界上最好的女朋友。”是的。她说：“是啊。”她简直不敢相信这事发生在下午的工作时间。那是她的顾虑。然后迈克尔有一个谈话头，他说本杰明·富兰克林原来是个变态。
And she's like, Michael, I'm, I'm like, and he's like, I'm sorry, are you mad? And she's like, I'm, like, close to firing you. And he's like, oh, what a relief. I have the best G.D. girlfriend in the world. Yeah. And she's like, yeah. She couldn't believe that it happened in the afternoon at work. That was her concern. And then Michael has the talking head where he says, Ben Franklin kind of turned out to be a creep.
而脱衣舞娘伊丽莎白给出了很棒的建议，而且还押韵。这真的让你怀疑为什么本杰明·富兰克林能成为总统，而像伊丽莎白这样的人却不能。这确实让你该死地怀疑。这叫厌女症，各位。我们开始吧。我确实喜欢他真的很欣赏她的建议押韵，因为我觉得这只是对那个来到学校演讲的巨大猫头鹰的回应。是的。是的。她有服装。
And Elizabeth the stripper gave great advice that rhymed. And it just really makes you wonder how Ben Franklin can become president, but someone like Elizabeth can't. It does make you effing wonder. It's called misogyny, everyone. Here we go. go. I do love that he really appreciated that her advice rhymed, because I feel like this is just that callback to that giant owl that came and spoke at a school. Yeah. Yes. She had a costume.
她用押韵说话。她真的打动了他。好吧，这是打动人的两种方式。你要么需要穿上服装，要么需要押韵。这些是非常有效的方法。好吧。我们这一集快结束了，但珍娜，有两个删减片段。我觉得值得一提。第一，在这一集的最开始，托比说：“迈克尔，你不能在工作时请脱衣舞娘，对吧？”当然人力资源部不会让这种事发生。哦，我一直想知道托比在这一切中在哪儿。
She talked in rhyme. She really got through to him. Well, those are the two ways to get through to people. You either need to dress up in a costume or rhyme. These are very effective ways. Okay. We're coming to the close of this episode, but Jenna, there were two deleted scenes. that I thought were worth mentioning. Number one, at the very beginning of the episode, Toby is like, Michael, you can't have strippers at work, right? Of course human resources would not let this happen. Oh, I've wondered where Toby was in all of this.
是的，所以他们绕过这个的方法是迈克尔只是说：“好吧，你知道吗，托比，你可以回家了。”然后另一个我觉得有点好笑的删减片段，凯文有一个谈话头，他分享说他给他的女朋友斯泰西买了一根脱衣舞杆作为生日礼物，但他不知道怎么安装。哦。所以他家里有一根没安装的脱衣舞杆。
Yeah, and so how they got around this is that Michael just says, well, you know what, Toby, you can just go home. And then the other deleted scene that I thought was kind of funny, where Kevin has a talking head and he shares that he bought his girlfriend, Stacy, a stripper pole for her birthday, but he doesn't know how to install it. Oh. So he has an uninstalled stripper pole in his house.
是的。这会是一个巨大的题外话，但你知道喜剧演员妮可·拜尔吗？哦，她有一根脱衣舞杆。她有一根脱衣舞杆，她在上面真的很厉害，她经常在Instagram上发布视频，她们在播客里谈论这个。她们说：这就像是一种锻炼。
Yeah. This is going to be a huge tangent, but you know the comedian Nicole Beyer. Oh, she has a stripper pole. She has a stripper pole and she's like real good on it and she's posts videos all the time on Instagram and they talk about it on their podcast. They're like, it's like an exercise.
现在。脱衣舞杆作为锻炼。是的。我不知道你尝试爬杆，像顺着杆子滑上去有多久了。有一阵子了。那暗示我曾经尝试过顺着脱衣舞杆滑上去。停下。不是脱衣舞杆。我只是想让你知道，当我观看妮可在Instagram上的视频时，我总是很惊讶，因为在操场上和孩子们在一起时，几年前，有那种消防员杆。你知道，你可以爬上游乐设施然后滑下来。孩子们在做那种顺着它往上蹭的动作。他们说：“妈妈，来吧。”珍娜，我离地只有两英尺。我说：“我做不到。”我在这方面太糟糕了。我最近尝试爬绳子，但我没爬多远。是的。我还尝试做一个侧手翻，结果我闪了腰
now. The stripper pole as exercise. Yeah. I don't know if it's been a while for you since you tried to crawl up a pole, like shimmy up a pole. Been a while. That implies I ever tried to shimmy up a stripper pole. Stop. Not a stripper pole. I just want you to know when I watch Nicole's videos on Instagram, I am always amazed because at the playground with the kids, like a few years ago, there was like the pole that's like the fireman's pole. You know, you can climb up the place structure and then slide down it. And the kids were doing the thing where they scooch up it. And they were like, Mom, come on. Jenna, I got like two feet off the ground. I was like, I can't. I'm so horrible at it. I tried to climb a rope recently and I didn't get far. Yeah. I also tried to do a cartwheel and I threw my back
。哦，但最糟糕的是当我尝试做一个前滚翻时，我真的扭伤了脖子。好吧，我觉得我不是脱衣舞杆的料。你还……它不在我的未来里。你可能也当不了悉尼。我开玩笑的。说吧。珍娜，我不知道。
out. Oh, but the worst is when I tried to do a somersault and I really jacked my neck. Well, I don't think I'm stripper pole material. You also... It's not in my future. You also maybe couldn't have been Sydney. I'm just kidding. Say it. Jenna, I don't know.
听着，你是一位杰出的演员。我没看到你做倒立，然后从后口袋里掏出一枚手榴弹，在你从桌子上翻下来时把它扔进窗户。好吧。你显然对我的局限性有强烈的看法。你知道吗？我和你一起带着吉他旅行，我看到了那是什么样子。你带着吉他穿过机场，把它带上飞机。这对你来说非常困难。
Listen, you are a phenomenal actress. I don't see you doing a, like, a handstand and, like, taking a, like, a grenade out of your back pocket and throwing it through a window as you flip off a table. Okay. You clearly have strong feelings about my limitations. You know what? I traveled with you with a guitar and I saw what it was like. You navigating a guitar through an airport, getting it on a plane. It was very difficult for you.
好吧。有道理。有道理。我会说这个。我最近买了。我很兴奋能得到它。一个便携式踢踏舞地板。这就是你吗？
All right. Fair enough. Fair enough. I will say this. I did recently purchase. I'm so excited to get it. A portable tap dancing floor. This is who you are?
是的。所以准备好迎接那个吧。我已经开始学习踢踏舞了，跳《Footloose》那首歌。我要给你发一段视频，我要穿上我的工装裤。我要在我的谷仓前，在我的便携式地板上跳舞。我会去坐在你车道的尽头，弹几下玻璃琴。Fru-da-Food-Foo-Fu-Fu-Fu-Fu-Fu-Fu-Fu。而我会尽情地跳我的踢踏舞。
Yes. So get ready for that. I've already started learning a tap dance to the song, Footloose. And I'm going to send you a video I'm going to put on my overalls. And I'm going to dance in front of my barn on my portable floor. I will come and sit at the end of your driveway and play a few glasses of the glass harmonica. Fru-da-Food-Foo-Fu-Fu-Fu-Fu-Fu-Fu. And I'm going to tap dance my little heart out.
伙计们，那是本杰明·富兰克林。在我们走之前，我们有安迪·戴利的最后一段音频片段。我很好奇，我必须知道，他是否扮演过任何其他历史人物或开国元勋？这是他要说的。我确实在《醉酒史》的一集里扮演过泰迪·罗斯福，那非常令人难忘。我骑了一匹马，戴了一副假胡子，那太棒了。但是，你知道，很久以前，回到2002年，我在纽约的UCB剧院排演了一个小品秀，
Guys, that's Ben Franklin. Before we go, we have a final audio clip from Andy Daley. I was curious, I had to know, has he ever played any other historic figures or founding fathers? Here's what he had to say. I did play Teddy Roosevelt in an episode of drunk history that was very memorable. I got to ride a horse and wear a fake mustache, and that was great. But, you know, a long time ago, back in I would say 2002, I put up a sketch show at the UCB Theater in New York,
其中一个小品是关于亚历山大·汉密尔顿与某人辩论联邦主义的，这听起来像是一个糟糕的喜剧小品，也许确实是。但我扮演了亚历山大·汉密尔顿，我的观点是林-曼努埃尔·米兰达看到了那个小品，并受到启发写了《汉密尔顿》。我一直觉得有点被剽窃了。就像是，你知道，写了汉密尔顿传记的罗恩·切尔诺能得到某种程度的认可，他因为启发了那部剧而受到赞誉，但我没有。
and one of the sketches was about Alexander Hamilton debating federalism with someone, which sounds like a terrible comedy sketch, and maybe it was. But I played Alexander Hamilton in that, and it is my opinion that Lynn Manuel Miranda, Miranda saw that sketch and was inspired to write Hamilton. And I've always felt kind of ripped off. Like it's, you know, it's nice that Ron Chernow, who wrote the Hamilton biography, gets kind of, he gets credit for the extent to which he inspired that play, but I am not.
你永远不会在剧目单或电影演职员表中看到我的名字。我只是非常方便地被完全遗忘了。我无法证明林-曼努埃尔·米兰达在观众席中或看过那个小品。但你知道，常识表明《汉密尔顿》就是那样产生的。但就是这样。泰迪·罗斯福、亚历山大·汉密尔顿和本杰明·富兰克林是我整个职业生涯中扮演过的仅有的开国元勋。哇。比我扮演的多三个开国元勋。我喜欢它。我喜欢安迪·戴利。伙计们，如果你想继续听这个非常、非常、非常有趣的人，你可以在他自己的Earwolf播客上找到他，叫《Bonanas for Bonanza》，这是一个关于经典西部
You will never see my name in the playbill or in the credits of the movie. I am just very conveniently, completely forgotten. And I can't prove that Lin-Manuel Miranda was in the audience or ever saw. that sketch. But you know, common sense dictates that that's how Hamilton came about. But that's it. Teddy Roosevelt, Alexander Hamilton, and Ben Franklin are the only founding fathers I have ever played in my entire career. Wow. Three more founding fathers than I've played. I love it. I love Andy Daley. You guys, if you want to keep listening to this very, very, very funny person, you can find him on his own Earwolf podcast called Bonanas for Bonanza, which is a rewatch podcast of the classic Western
电视剧《Bonanza》的重温播客。你也可以在Twitter和Instagram上找到他，账号是TV's Andy Daily。他的姓氏拼写是D-A-L-Y。我迫不及待想听那个播客了。我以前和我爸爸一起看《Bonanza》。是安迪·戴利。这就是你需要知道的一切。好了。
TV show, Bonanza. You can also find him on Twitter and Instagram at TV's Andy Daily. His last name is spelled D-A-L-Y. I cannot wait to listen to that podcast. I used to watch Bonanza with my dad. It's Andy Daly. That's all you need to know. All right.
好吧，非常感谢你们发送问题，感谢你们听我们唠叨我们做的所有这些深入研究。这对我们来说很有趣。我们喜欢这一集。我们希望你们大家有一个很棒的一周。是的，我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。
Well, thank you guys so much for sending in your questions for listening to us. ramble on about all of these deep dives we did. This was a lot of fun for us. We love this episode. And we hope you guys have a great week. Yeah, we'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔金斯。我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins. And our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Office Ladies是由Odyssey呈现，由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的执行制片人是Cassie Jorkins。我们的音频工程师兼助理制片人是Molly Nugent。Odyssey的执行制片人是Leah Reese Dennis。Office Ladies由Bill Shultz进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的《Rubber Tree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。